en donc le complot est chez soi mais là
un contre nous puisque en fait j'ai pas
pu créer la reine a encore pascal a re
démarrage du serveur qui en cours et
donc ils m'attaquent banon tu ne peux
pas créé on ne sait pas donc voir où
c'est la passe de quoi va parler le
stream en fait un passage normalement ça
va être redémarré dans deux minutes mais
on ne sait pas si un bug
moi je ne peux pas jouer pour l'instant
alors là tu ne peux rien faire là
d'accord on peut discuter
en fait c'est toi passer encore toi
c'est beau à chaque fois que tu es là
c'est fantastique pas d'échec
y'a pas des chocolats on ne peut même
plus jouer là attends je laisse arena
avec salir la ccfi billy j'ai tout
changé a partout sauf là où ça fait le
coup si les gens veulent discuter ya pas
de problème les personnes parlent d'un
chat ne sont ils pas d'échiquier donc le
site intéressant attends j'ai regardé
mon compte est arrivé ou pas d'ailleurs
s'ils viennent pas ils viennent pas à 51
pas de chance mais le risque aujourd'hui
est le changement d'horaire kamerhe
changement d'horaire du conte n'a pu
repasser à 13h leur mieux mais tête du
coup les gens sont dits aura pas de live
et puis enfin ils seront courant dans
trois jours on ne sait pas de quoi jeudi
en fait aujourd'hui ça à 13 heures parce
qu'on a pu changer de temps grâce au
changement d'heure
oui à sa guise et redémarrer ainsi les
musées comme il faut j'avais envie de la
paix comme arena
bonjour monsieur pour changer j'en ai
marre naplouse on joue entendu je sais
pas si on vous envoie enfin on laisse
les gens démarrer puis tête ont joué
quelques parties ont fait peut-être un
peu les deux qua non membres de la
pédagogie
ouais mais bon je peux pas les créer
mais peut-être on regarde un peu les
parties des gens après on en joue qui on
regarde on peut faire les deux en fait
parce que c'est un tournant on peut
sortir et rentrer les serveurs en train
de redémarrer ce serait bon en fait que
gerra m 2 heures à redémarrer n'ont pas
de chance la fin du stream bombe
je fais des flashs quand même ça ça et
ça je peux bordel j'ai le droit
c'est pourquoi
nous avons un échiquier déjà nous ça
serait fun inimaginaux là je pense que
je fais je fais de la merde en fait j'ai
des cavaliers venus imagine au jeu et ça
va on peut contourner
c'est pas grave tu passe comme ça vous
allez sont parfois ses cages
je passe complètement au tissu battu
avec moi j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
il y affronte fille qui vit au bas on
dirait un stream d'hikaru non merci
enfin bon stream bien comme il faut et
chez des diagonales
je m'occupe du coloriage colère des
kaizer des casques bleus je fais de la
couleur un mondial le logo windows
ah oui carrément c'est quoi la troyenne
le n'est ce pas je sais plus c'est
peut-être deux bleus non non ce double
c'était triste bones jaune ouais ouais
j'ai pas de jaune c'est jaune gaspacho
mais bon vous savez la casio 4 et un peu
jaune quoi natanz et je peux bien on
essaye les échiquiers
moi ça me déplaît pomme c'est un peu
triste
ouais a chance on me faire un très
intéressant l'on peut regarder tous les
échiquiers de chasse comme bien 8 bits
très moche attend ça c'est les pièces
attend faut qu'on fasse avions fait un
double 8 bits be c'est tellement la
merde ça au rugby au plus haut la neige
qui est éco plus mesdames et messieurs
ok cela j'aime bien vite avec tts alpha
blondy reste rixe 3way voyez pas mal
celui-là ouais bah ouais c'est pas
terrible on a vu mieux comme beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus çà çà çà çà çà voilà
ça déjà du qualitatif
ça ressemble à genuis tu te rappelles
way ministre un jeu avec genius mauges
des petits a été fort mélodies gps gts
comme en pls vous aussi bas bois plus
heureux de voir leurs serveurs mais il
est beau suis là bas c'est souvent des
extrêmes là dessus nous banon suivant là
est vraiment là jamais il suit la tête
on pourrait l'utiliser plus souvent avec
les pièces base fait fait un vote pour
nous dire marc messieurs est bon les
gars et merci à monsieur luca pour pour
le tweak prix merci tonton merci bon
direct on a fait un stream de qualité l
aveugle un nez plus de pièces candidats
très bon nombre de dames 1 4 swing gum
ces pièces là c'est comment les vieux
livres russe oui mais j'y qui est non
jeudi 13 stade français qua non des
gages et un peu de pouvoir bois nous
dire que
non j'aime pas bois sombre ouais ça
c'est gros sont ces sombres comme sasuke
mais en fait beaucoup plus intéressant
que l'aréna en fait c'est en fin de
rencontre en train de faire sa ba
l'assodas tout de suite oh [ __ ] les
pièces rose j'ai bien aimé y est super
beau cela avec les pièces par manon wesh
wesh bon plusieurs nuits bon pourquoi
pas cessé ses créatifs trop normal et
puis un peu petit les pièces l'annoncé
des nains le cas libyen est un mange de
la soupe dégage
ouais c'est pas mal le classique un bon
avec toucycois oui mais ça fait toujours
son effet qu avec du vieux en petit bois
verni dessous ben ça glisse semblait
bien vernis tu peux faire coulisser t
pièce tu l'âge est là comme un truc de
curling le pion des deux trucs et puis
vendent et 4 très facilement attention
quand on veut la ruine des pions peu
avancé de deux cases sur le vernis
sérieux aux caisses le club hu
mais ça c'est les pièces duchess kid oui
très moche il en faut peu dans le flou
ouais mais c'est accueil dans les vieux
livres français sa médaille d'or était
très énervé quoi mais il a l'air plus
fort nantes a pas trop envie l'échanger
contre une tour pays très fort il a un
casque
tu vois il a une lan ce qui va arriver
il va me défoncer quoi fin du volume ne
puisse plus plus fort en milieu de jeu
lui c'est même franchement même les
cavaliers ont l'air très nerveux voire
très rapidement ouais bah je pensais
toujours en fait c'est complètement de
la merde là dégage la tour comptant
contre un cavalier tout de suite quoi
dégage je ne veux plus voir cette pièce
c'est pas mal mais enfin sympa
d'ailleurs la dame noire est beaucoup
plus belle que la dame blanche ça faut
le savoir
voilà des détails très commenta centre
met d'ailleurs les tournois rossif à
toutes les pièces phares sont beaucoup y
voient la soie lacé on va le payer très
beau pas mal hein
méribel pièces en pleine charge parce
qu'on change paraître plus souvent amers
de grâce est le préféré de sa villa d'or
mer de glace la couleur de l'échiquier
très heureux au cic s'est en fait ouais
by mer de glace ici si haye si tu vois
comme glacée et si comme mr bah je salue
mes yeux les bobos et comme on joue la
mère de la jeune fille c'est quoi ces
conneries mais en fait en fait très bien
c'est un jeu de mots en fait ouais ouais
c'est ça mehdi je suis content je devais
mettre l'échiquier pour peut-être pour
960 belle allée tour en l'air solide
joie et c'est vrai que la vie de mère
c'est là tu fais des trucs comme ça
cavalier dit viens pas bien ce que c'est
non mais j'ai failli aux appareils et
pas très fort chanson va faire un string
comme ça même une vidéo youtube quoi on
découvre les échiquiers de chasse comme
bayard entre les parties je crois que
j'aime pas trop là bas il est peut être
la dame elle fait un peu aliens quatuor
avec trois doigts le faut par contre
j'aime bien le cavalière un peu triste
non mais tu pense pas qu'on pourrait
faire un une équipe
elles ont choisi une pièce de chacun on
fait une super tour lequel est très fort
le faut avec son casque et c'est quoi
c'est pas comment faire en fait aux
[ __ ] c'est la nage la baie les pièces
jamia en fait les pièces et les frites
choisi comme tu veux tu peux aller
choisir séparés mais tu peux pas il
prend une pièce de loin et mâchonnant
ouais mais là c'est là c'est glacé quoi
enfin quand cette règle à cette
attention je ne sors pas d'ailleurs le
bel âge mais je me confine devant si je
vais fouler 5 il va faire [ __ ] foot et
roanne ont rappelé avec l'inertie tu
arrives angers 5-1 totalement à 6 ont
fait très mal et il n'est pas facile à
manger parce que le pion y est les
cavalières mon avis on en sueur non non
il est curieux ou alors peut-être y
glisse un peu et après ils complètement
ralenti réussit pas à tourner quoi coup
légal ou illégal très difficile attend
les ir triche
elle fouille est intéressant c'est
futuriste mais un futur raté c'est un
peu un peu une pandémie qui aura déçu
mais tout le monde est heureux que j'ai
que des pièces comme ça tu as un peu de
la merde mais ok bravo pour les forfaits
mer de glace
bon vous l'échiquier j'aime pas trop
mais les pièces week mer de glace et
gamme le grand quel âge pensez ça les
chiffres comme les parties d'ordi quoi
ouais ouais bon mais qu'est-ce que
graffitis ouais mais offre qu elles sont
pas gratuites et moche mais en ayant une
quantité incroyable et celui-ci tient
parchemin sa jumelle en démarrant parce
que bon c'est vrai que tu te croirais à
l'époque de champollion là tu te dis ah
tiens je vais déchiffrer tout ça c'est
pas si mal en fait mike pas mal de tête
on devrait prendre ça pour les vieilles
parties c'est vrai vous devrez rendre
échanger d'échiquier en fait sur les
séries ouais ouais vous faire revivre je
prenne parti 2e
je dois même parti 2e de là dessus quand
même comme ça on regarde non ça pue la
merde mais à sable batié vieille partie
aussi avec cet échiquier en sable ouais
mais c'est beau en fait front l'a jamais
fait bachelor vient de déployer web
on est très créatif je sais vous allez
c'est tellement bien en fait les ce
reboot qu il n'y a pas d'échec en fait
c'était en fait intéressant on découvre
tellement de choses en fait
non mais c'est vraiment ça fait
égyptien bain et partie des lunes bas
c'est mon frère là dessus aussi alors
tiens est ce que tu sais à qui étaient
les premiers à faire à la poste courrier
je ne sais pas je veux dire par là les
onglets et par l'egypte antique a déjà
eu ville ils ont fait des routes c'est
avec leur petit char et ils envoyaient
des lettres et questions
ce que quand tu as apporté ton courrier
bombero l'oblitérer tout ça est ce que
déjà les qte en serpentin alors en fait
c'était pas pour les combos comme nous
enfin c'était pas envoyé un courrier
pour dire je vais bien c'était que
l'état c'est fou pour trouver des impôts
non mais c'est genre pharaons pharaons
qui écris tu vois c'est à l'armée
christophe quoi ouais ouais mais
c'étaient les premiers d'aller des
routes avec des chars qui à la faune et
après la première poste vraiment
développé et qui a pu commencer enfin
qui était vraiment très développés
s'étaient postés rome très intéressant
je te recommande vraiment la vidéo de
nota bene la tuyère je regrette en 20
minutes c'était génial
et ils n'en revenaient pas des des
colissimo avec des petits oiseaux qui
transportait le courrier ci baisse ça
c'était l'écran est très rapide ce matin
mais ils avaient des systèmes de postes
sans endroit prester les pigeons qui a
l'air fou c'est le supplément pigeon
quoi à y avait tout le temps il voulait
en moins de 24 heures tu l'as acheté un
pigeon mais ils te disent du coup nota
bene il te dit que les les empires qui
avait une poste c'était signe d'un
empire très puissant qui très difficile
d'avoir une poste il faut déjà avoir
beaucoup de route il faut avoir beaucoup
de chevaux qui courent à fond parce
qu'ils sont là et il faut avoir un état
fort militairement pour qu'il soit
protégé aussi s'attaquer ton courrier
peu mais dont qui disent que enfin avoir
une poste à l'époque c'est c'est très
palace quoi mais nous en ferons sociaux
ni la poste après mais beaucoup plus
tard mais deux mille ans plus tard quoi
tous les français nous avons assisté à
deux bosses aussi on est très bien
préparé on à la poste
restez-vous que les égyptiens antiques
ou en 1500 ils ont ils ont un poste nous
xviiie siècle on est là quoi 3000 ans
après we petit j'avais les premiers ont
eu mais apprendre avec un système de
post le
le meilleur d'europe enfin même très
attention on était quand même très
développé le monde nous enviait quoi
ouais et il y avait même une loi qui
interdisait aux chevaux normaux de
courir à au galop payés que les chevaux
postaux qui avaient droit donc en fait
si tu voulais courir vite à fond tu
étais obligé de battre cet été obligé de
louer un cheval à la poste et du coup
les thaïs les districts sur ta gueule
quoi les biens cheval ne pas être à la
fois ci en parallèle au galop je tends
vers avec l'opl à part sur le reçu le
tampon quoi ouais du tourmalet au galop
mais en fait il faisait arrêter tu tapes
à leroy ton choix c'est un drapeau
haussier sont 35 euros damende tu n'as
pas le certificat la poste et du coup ça
m'a donné envie de lire le livre de
saint-exupéry pas le petit prince il
autre courrier de nuit ou comment il
s'appelle déjà se livrent à spa courrier
de nuit un vol de nuit goldoni veulent
donner ma lénine de mort ouais bah ouais
aussi mais à autre chose mais vol de
nuit je me suis saint-exupéry ça va être
intéressant parce que t il été postiers
oui bah les pilotes des avions fait le
plein de choses ouais et est à fond des
trails sont très inquiets ne trouve pas
la mire de l'aréna alors à quand est-ce
que c'est particulièrement mais ça parle
de quoi aujourd'hui il va on teste les
échiquiers pensons qu'un truc très bien
non mais c'était beau la loi tu n'as pas
besoin d'aller au trot ou au galop avec
son cheval il te faut un choc de poids
s'il te paye des amendes mais j'adore en
fait comment ils vous voulez toujours
rasé du fric genres les styles toujours
assez du fritz est n'a pas changé enfin
pour le mans n'y a pas d'arrêt mais
qu'on ne peut pas jouer le truc et en
redémarrage ne sais pas alors est ce que
ça marche très moche l'échiquier du
couteau de retrouvrions que je peux
faire voir du sable voilà attend à voir
s'ils marchent maintenant
la preuve arena ouais ça a l'air de
marcher on m'a à travers 30 du coût mais
vous êtes résident pour arriver à là il
veut pas bosser mais si tu défies
quelqu'un tu peux jouer là tu peux jouer
samedi à 14h fois il veut bien
13h35 qui veut bien
13h30 non on ne l'aimé arena le suisse
ouais bien sûr milliards il ya plein de
gens qui voulaient faire suisse bâle
c'est bon je leur ai dit non rien écrit
attention pourquoi pas 14h c'est un peu
tôt bah ouais mais à moi je fixe et un
peu tard bon on a changé d'heure donc
vous non mes trésors 13h15 ses liens à
14h pourquoi 14 heures du mans jacques
allard pas à l'os et voilà ça j'ai prévu
le coup que si bon il a rien bon je vais
vraiment gêné d'ailleurs j'ai fait un
truc très bien j'étais très heureux je
fais des lentilles corail lait de coco
tout ça tu trouves tu que la chanson de
julien doré cocaïne ouais mais ça y est
on est d'accord que ça fasse ça veut
rien dire c'est à dire beaucoup de
choses et très peu à la fois on est bien
d'accord
oui ma deux ans je comprends jamais les
paroles de celui de julien doré ou en
généralement je ne rajoute pas j'entends
des trucs pnlt coûte un peu opaque et
non juste le groupe arrive je comprends
très bien les ports là c'est grand paris
bon il ya cap j'ai le droit qui joue
bordel banane verte réalité ils sont
tous là à quoi m c'est l'heure de la
sieste vous êtes dur ouais mais attendez
les mecs là on a vraiment rien à [ __ ]
en ce moment cerci jamais la sieste à 15
ou 16 heures bon parce que ça change
vraiment quelque chose
bah ouais et genre des choses à faire
jara si je te dis on est mardi parce que
ce que ce sera un problème ça c'est un
truc de ouf on est dimanche mais ça
change absolument rien à lundi quand non
bon faudrait peut-être michel drucker
regarder la télé je ne sais pas mais
michel drucker
comment s'inscrire dans le but de ce
type ne club bitstream
il faut quelqu'un mettre le lien dans le
tchat mes grands-parents et garde michel
drucker le dimanche à la télé dans un
canapé rouge
ils sont très heureux de michel drucker
j'arrive enfin bon c'est quand même 40
ans qui fait le truc longuement non
justement ça voudrait rassurer israël
sont très rassurés qu'ils admirent du
coup une visite au caire où tout est
normal to one michel drucker et la voilà
monsieur luca qui a une qui met les
petits liens jeu l'office ou qu'ils en
profitent tant qu'il est là et attend
mais je crois est ce que c'est vrai est
ce que c'est fait avec nous un truc
beaucoup moins drôle j'ai ya quelqu'un
qui m'a dit qu'il y avait un souci avec
la femme de tarot nian ouais mais je
sais pas je sais peut-être fait que nous
obtenons des jeux de type de type
d'essai quoi oui je sais pas mais je
n'arrive pas à ça
j'arrive pas nombreux donc on saura rien
non je sais pas j'espère ses fonctions
je sais pas ouais
mais
je sais pas je ne sais pas je sais pas
vous voir enfin il ya aucun site qui a
vraiment à relayer le truc con que c'est
pas du tout confirmé où elle avait eu un
accident de voiture il ya deux semaines
de ça c'était loi de temps d'acheminer
des candidats je crois c'était la veille
non le jour du début non mais enfin je
pensais que ça devrait aller mais il se
disait dans les news et à stabiliser
tout donc c'est assez rassurant en
quelque sorte voisins mais le truc c'est
que bombe après peur balle et le bronze
au sénat mais les commotions cérébrales
c'est un sale truc un risque d'un coup
tu peux c'est pour eux de jeunes pas moi
j'ai connu ça n'a pas très longtemps
dans ma famille aussi simple je subisse
un sort aux va mieux et non ouais en
fait tu dois parler de ça parce que
sinon ça m intéresse
du coup voilà du coup on doit refaire
les échiquiers quoi pour repartir sur
sur un sujet quand même beaucoup plus
intéressant enfin pas plus intéressant
mais beaucoup plus joyeux quoi yeux du
coup on est et on était sur le liffe
arch west rider c'est pour les parties
de même une bassine du coup c'était
quelle pièce que j'ai trouvé qu'ils
étaient bien pour les high party là
c'est celle là
non non non des tirs potter pour
annoncer marche ça non non un peu malade
a une tête d'alien quoi mais bon être
une 3d ce qu'est ce que c'est moche
je n'arrive pas à voir comme ça t'arrive
pas assez trop de toi qui as utile mais
qui veut tout le temps jouer en 3d c'est
à dire franchement en fait c'est pas un
mandat 3d à la 2d qui tentent d'imiter
pitoyablement de la 3f de déchets ce qui
ne devrait pas disputer
qu'est ce que j'ai envie de faire
bayonne 3 2 il a un fichu tain c'est
très intéressant ça va on pourrait faire
ça sans c'est génial et ça y est c'est
de la vraie 3d voilà ce que te dis
lunettes 3d attends je vais scandinaves
en 3 min c'est de la vraie vie mais je
pense que les gens vous aimeriez avant
des vidéos avec des vrais 3d on pourrait
le faire
peut-être qu'on peut regarder ça mais en
plus avec ça aujourd'hui mais tu peux
pas on voit qu'on peut suivre l'aréna
avec ça vous avez bien ou pas ne plus
voir comment ça fait les flèches quoi à
ce que les flèches sont troubles ya pas
de flèches mais il ya les couleurs
ce que tu sens le bts fluides parce que
vous êtes bien ouais ça glisse bien en
vrai j'aime pas du tout elle c'est une
question d'habitude tu en penses quoi
bon on peut tester un jeu comme ça
change quoi c'est élitiste ou pas tant
virage en regard de chat
disons voire mal les pièces non mais
faut s'habituer mais en fait c'est pas
pire ou pas mieux enfin c'est juste une
autre chose moins lisible ont préféré
des vidéos avec des vraies analyses
plutôt qu'avec de la vraie 3d
ouais bon voilà c'est être pas idiot
pour les gens qui veulent s'entraîner
jouer en 3d est ce que je m'enrichis
qu'après du coup c'est mieux de sites a
beaucoup fait comme ça je veux les jeux
gameboy ingrédients qui aime on ne sait
pas c'est marrant en tout cas je savais
pas qu'il y avait cette option sur place
comme peuple bien présent ses origines
nature je sais pas je savais pas que ça
existait toi tu savais ou pas non ayala
tu peux l'utiliser en vr peut-être avec
le casque
surtout il aime ça surtout il aime ça
c'est ça qui est ça qui est important
on teste pour aujourd'hui c'est innovant
on essaye on peut essayer un pourquoi
pas moi ça me fait un peu mal aux yeux
de base mais peut-être dit ça mais frank
zappa il veut je dise ne réplique de jeu
c'est pas comme le web
c'est spécial calme mais original qu'il
n'ya pas les flèches le très mauvais a
dit sais plus qui a dit ça mais
quelqu'un à temps j'avoue le chat à côté
on peut changer la couleur des quatre
alors à temps est-ce qu'on peut changer
les embouts en mesure font il faut que
je n'étais du coup on met du bois du
boom dernier il va falloir que je dis 5
ouais ben ouais franchement franchement
ça a de la gueule qui peut s'asseoir à
la table de chess comédies les plus
beaux échiquier que toi fab madame je
sais pas personne ne veut asseoir je
pense
non franchement c'est pareil ce qui
honnêtement c'est quand même assez bien
réussie même si pour moi c'est un peu
bizarre machin et touche prouve que
c'est assez bien réussie parce que les
autres trucs en 3d que j'avais vu par le
passé c'était juste chiant
ouais bah il fallait du collyre pour
supporter le truc parce que sinon
conjonctivite assurez la beaucoup mieux
là mes yeux respire je me sens pas mal
d'argent je suis en perez avec avec
messi troyen dehors quoi ce matin je
comptais les abeilles au nombre de cinq
quoi elle chante que ça pousse là il ya
du bon butinage à faire est de plus en
plus en fait pas au début on avait une
qui a pris on a eu deux puis trois puis
quatre puis aujourd'hui s'il y en a une
genre de 4 qu'il ya dans le bio enfin
elle doit me reconnaître et oui le coup
on était proche des citronniers déjà
peut-être ici lui aussi échoué à butiner
j'en sais rien peut-être qu'on réduise
la taille de nos têtes dit pascal bour
mais alors ça c'est pas facile ce qu'il
faudrait changer tout le designer et
agrandir j sheekey c'est beau le design
avec le taureau des candidats
ouais j'ai gardé comme ça après un
empêchement ça serait bien l'échiquier
comme ça et white ont font vert en
incrustant je peux tenter un nouveau
prêt moi je sais pas mais ça en fait des
pas en afrique ça près non roger aucune
clause schipper assez bien on fait c'est
chic et cash nos gueules quoi google
non mais en fait c'est justement ce
kilomètre très très grand quoi toi tu
l'aurais voulu être comme ça mais on a
rappelé le monde et joueurs après ça ça
pose quelques problèmes techniques
faudrait tout remettre en place et qu'un
nom des joueurs sur le côté des choses
comme ça il faudrait carrément changer
tout le design en fait tu vas voir jouer
en un échiquier numéro 1 entre chelsea
et battu avec les chics et en 3d fait
beaucoup j'ai très bien c'est bon je ne
joue plus on de déchets sont évadés des
verts ce qu'ils disent et les ouais
enfin c'est laisser les enfants
commencent déjà quand je parle parler
poliment bon mais d'aude et non en fait
d'accord je m'en fou n'importe quoi
comme tu le sens je quitte ce strip cet
échiquier n'appartient pas ce stream
comment at il pu être un échiquier six
mois je crois que est ce vraiment
étonnant
il est mm notre attention
non non il est 13h 29m a changé d'heure
mais c'est mon site de voir le jeu des
noirs bah oui mais très dur de voir le
jeu des bleus
je suis sûr que si je suis retourné
retourner ça vous faire mal au coeur
qu'on aura envie de vomir c'est elle qui
a le vote vague sur un bateau ouais
il manque plus que le cadre de réalité
virtuelle et on va se sentir grands
maîtres tels si on peut voir une sur une
partie lambda ouais je pense à on peut
suivre des gens lambda suivant des
landes
il faut bosser qu'on ait joué ici on
lambda quoi ariane tahri or mais ne l'a
même pas jouer que sur dans l'échiquier
3d voilà ça jouer à fond quoi mes
chevaux ils sont marrants au milieu
qu'on ait un qui regarde la gauche vers
la droite mais se regarde on fait grève
bordel j'ai le droit de bouger quand
elle quoi bon j'aime bien les noirs
manger ce cheval c'est presque fait
vatan et ont cueilli resteront tout le
mange dans votre sphère h4 mais on va te
défoncer boom mais je pense que le
défonçant il fait juste h4 les envois
jusqu'à quatre noms pleutre de très peu
d'options mais alors revenir faire il va
perdre et c'est très bien ces traits
plus au 3e rang 32 secondes à attendre
mais en fait elle est protégée à tour un
bel adam différence ce sont des grands
maîtres attention souvenant qu eric haïk
et noir il ya un gros avantage la pendue
il peut le gagner comme ça soit les
pires aussi sous un truc comme ça 5 je
pense chez coraud chez kiabi fr materi
clairement non
l'émoi de choses
ouais non peut-être sont très énervés
parce que ça mange plus dehors et où
enfin ben oui j'ai vu que dans certaines
villes les oiseaux sont très énervés
mais ils sont très énervés
elle voulait fonder manche ne mange plus
nous sommes plutôt minette way son très
énervé à juste titre un ba oui on
travaille plus pour eux ah c'est beau en
fait nous penser que la nature serait
très heureuse qu'on arrête de vivre en
fait sur tous très énervé c'est qu'on
pense que c'est moins polluer quand on
est très heureux bon en fait c'est
complètement de la merde on s'était
habitué quoi ils vont nous dire que les
dauphins sont heureux on nage dans les
ports voit d'ailleurs et déjà des gens
qui sont inquiets disent oui ils vont
coûter bâton voir venir avant de perdre
l'habitude que c'est dangereux et
attention ça vaut qu'un vent de face le
dauphin à fond pour les sauver quoi
c'est une belle partie c'est très
intéressant du haut niveau et c'est au
tour sur ses pulsions bon ben on
choisira restera vous intéressante
il rejoue barricou je pense je le remets
ton donné envie nettement wes pas gage
d'accord manche en passant deux des
femmes
je reprends
le niveau très faible quand je ne vois
plus rien par contre on peut choisir
l'échiquier qu'on va mettre non alors je
vais choisir je choisir un chanson la
fcd rei donc peut-être salle de jeux
pour les pièces parce que c'est des
treilles et l'échiquier à l'oise
c'est la loose elle est maman
mais aussi qui parce qu'on l'armée
orange rappelle celle et il y avait ces
échiquier là en portable avec cette
couleur se rappelle pas c'était aussi
truc d'europe de l'est eux les jeudis 6
qu'ils respirent ouais il a été comme ça
un peu mon chemin je te rappelle pas
malade il en avait un automatiquement
très beau du coup s'est dit samedi que
les yeux ouais mais c'est pour voir un
peu qui a les yeux enfin si tu as des
yeux de fragile pas saturer les yeux
sinon on voit non cfoot et yeux sont
très opposées l'échiquier tron pour cet
homme moi je suis un peu mais ça fait
très tchèque je trouve ouais à cerner
chef au celi il fallait passer à ces
fauves n'en est pas mal quand celui-là
même pas
bros manque un peu de contraste
peut-être pas c'est un peu un peu de
tigres blancs qua non match aussi
c'est le genre d'autres frissons et
chicken bas sable mais c'est pas
terrible en cuir parchemin
je pense qu'on voit bien même journal un
entraîneur le pire de tous était
vraiment utilisé il existait vraiment
ouais dans les journaux mais en fait
encore c'est supportable c'est un
échiquier une position fixe un diagramme
mail à avoir des pièces de jouer là
dessus et ça c'est pas bon at on doit
s'habituer à tout parti c'est parti là
bas on ne remet tait être le bleu n'ont
au final où alfa pour les mâles alphas
n'en attend
bleu mais quoique sa maladie avec le rsa
c'est chaud puis je trouve pas ce que je
veux femmes mais à trop de choix
bam et bleu mais mais mais mais mais mer
de glace mais bleus savent peut-être pas
mais avec le reste du design au tour
dans ton pays très pauvre est une heure
là dessus ce soir on regarde déjà les
bleus je trouve qu'il est sympa il est
agréable à l'oeil
bon alors public hier il était leader
pendant longtemps et fils a craqué sur
la fin
et qu'est ce qu'ils gagnent
il dit qu'il y promenait au bois pour
les pièces et bois de noyer pour
l'échiquier mes pièces ne sont pas mal
gré c'est des pièces classiques chaise
comme en fait non voilà en restant neo
et on reste en bleu les néo l'élu prg
battant il a quoi y'a une pièce de plus
avec et noir ouais bah ça se passe très
bien présent puis copier la cua pied
dans la place je suis tellement plus que
je prends souvent apprendrez à faire
trop après quoi mais je pense que danger
moral entre la fondation et encore kate
hudson stratège et 5 mois ci sous mais
en fait même sa femme c'est fou était
peut-être même m'a même encore mieux
ouais mais katie est donné quoi
comme ça ça me fait peur et windham là
bas les tours je vais arriver je sais
pas non mais tu as raison il a fait tout
prendre et 6000 enfin bref le taf et qui
prend des six wells en 2005 quoi c'est
fou ce que je te dis ça joue pas mal
quand même
bon ben là c'est la première que le
temps de se chauffer mais dommage bon je
pense que les normes ont gagné ouais
mais c'est dommage d'avoir raté kg 5 et
m6 web se remettre du piment à la partie
et n'ont été sûrement toujours mieux
ouais c'est tête de série numéro en tête
de série numéro deux femmes un nom mais
gardez tout en sueur pour se jouer bien
le dire tu me wade a très bien fait je
pense que tu as un pouvoir sur les
commentaires de john pose mon style que
ouais non mais quand ces mêmes hier
savait pas si mal quoi surtout les
premiers échiquiers pour la première
partie ouais mais bon c'est dimanche une
grosse soirée samedi gueule de bois faut
se remettre
enfin non même la chance moi tu penses
qu'ils la gagnent quand même avec
terreur facile oui je consigne possible
l'évalution tu vas leur diamant un set
je suis pas aussi d'accord que ça je
vous sais pas si simple que moins 7
il y avait moins sept plus simple à
gagner celui-là oui bon c'est gagnant
mais a fréquemment j'aurais pensé que
c'est moins trois à temps une question
très intéressante la de shadow whitten
fabien de ces questions auraient check
check in et commenter un antique
oreilles car je vais m'en faire alors
j'ai fait j'ai pris 2 poireaux fabien
vous êtes ukrainien
comment est ce que vous avez commencé à
parler français la naissance ma
naissance alberto
bon le redis corail du coup ouais j'ai
pris de poireaux alors ça c'est une idée
à moi de façon d oignon quoi le poireau
comme c'est le poireau français de paris
tu vois ronnie s'éloigne on est quoi
donc ok deux poids aux scoops
j'ai pris une gousse d'ail l'a bien
petit à petit dans une casserole au jeu
croissance one toile un move to tu veux
enfin peu importe je fais revenir à
l'huile d'olive
quand tu en as marre tu balances était
anti corail ah bon ça c'est fait après
tu remplis d'eau ça dépasse un peu ce
sera un peu plus d'eau que de l'anti
quoi tu laisses moi je mets pas mal de
pury avec tout ça le de poires donc et
très bien et j'ai mis une boîte de
tomates concassées sasp obligatoire mais
c'est bien et qu'est ce que tu peux
faire d'autre après et bien au bout d'un
moment tu mets ton lait de coco et ça
tient tous deux très bons à lafarge
tavaux de korian dans ce temps-là bon
j'en avais pas je mets du quartier pas
pareil mais tu fais ce que tu veux mais
ni l'un ni l'autre d'ailleurs
et toujours à tuer voilà c'est pas mal
mais pourquoi les lentilles corail et je
sais pas surtout qu'elle pousse pas en
mer donc je n'ai pas compris en fait je
voudrais que des lentilles d'une
barrière de corail et que c'est très
compliqué les ramasse noms comme ceux
des lentilles elle pousse en terre ça
ressemble au d'alindien ouais tu as fait
et puis tu peux faire avec du risque
d'ailleurs très bien pour les
végétariens parce que si tu mélanges des
légumineuses lentilles et du riz par
exemple à tous les acides aminés donc ça
remplace n'était pas un peu mais bon là
tu vois pas deux comme ça
je prends ce qu'il a servi d'abord quoi
je sers pas je pense qu'il ya ba si vous
mangez de la viande mange de la viande
ne pas faire mais je fais tes courses
kamal enfin dans tous les cas où huit
mois non je n'ai pas la boucherie n'ai
rien fait la job les courses c'est
beaucoup de pâtes n'arrivèrent pas là
fondamentalement non mais oui je choisis
ce que je mange mais mais comme on
dirait dans temps normal si je vais au
resto quoi je prendrais pas de la viande
j'ai pas acheté machin mais là bon s'il
faut manger pour manger mais tu vas
justement non en restaurant à bages et
plus du tout aux attentes et reprend
ainsi si on prend puis rien mais
inquiète a quand même ce truc qui peut
être reprochée 6h s'être 6 et notamment
qu un tempo mais ici jeunes talents
encore tempo voilà ça se jouerait ton
preuve comme toujours c'est tellement
fort l'échec ces amendes et tu pouvais
jouer deux coups quater un joker projet
deux coups ça changerait tellement le
cours de plaintes partie 10 buts à rien
à temps partiel non mais oui et non on
fait c'est à dire que fait je dit pas
bien de ma vie quoi mais quand même j'ai
un crème de guti droit j'ai décidé
d'asseoir une case j'ai décidé de
stopper la viande donc pas forcément à
100 % mais quasiment donc flexitariens
voilà mais la tendance quand même pas je
peux passer cinq mois sans manger à vous
dire en quoi donc fortement végétarien
quand même tu passé cinq mois sans
manger un budget ça doit te suis invitée
chez quelqu'un et qui m'en sers j'en ai
mangé pendant 35 ans bah ça va je suis
patient je rongeais ya pas de problème
ça le regarde on regarde ce que fait pu
view compte relish parce qu'en fait
reiniche il et je sais qu'il est très
dangereux qui riche en fait tu sais que
tu veux beaucoup mieux que son
classement et du coup je suis curieux de
voir s'il peut super résister contre
tous
coupe way malgré tout si méfiants suite
à celle ci se dégage mieux pour les
blancs un petit peu jean trucage 3 et
des quatre jeux des cinq patients à
bouger cas très important je pense sarah
maintenant pour les rares ouais mais
c'est mieux de faire bouger ça votre
savoir-faire des cinq et il a carrément
gagner le thème pour 1,6 par rapport à
quand tu fais tes seins que je parte
rendre fou g5 pourquoi de faire
racketter mais c'est ça donc bon preuve
de plus ou moins actives et ouais c'est
ça que je pense n'est pas n'appartenait
pas à la position et c'est à chaque 10
lagoutte sa cause de l'avion de l'alcool
ou en c1 tout ça tu sais que ton mais
j'oubliais bassila bien non mais c'est
un peu tout fait à trop d'acide urique
donc c'est le choix je crois pas c'est
quoi je sais même pas d'où ça sort et si
je sais plus je perds mes trucs mais
après tout est reproduit 3 des studios
rich et tu le german tout le monde en
produits en fait mais dans l'entente
corps encore réguler et moi très mal
donc tout ce qui est source de si dur il
faut que je diminue donc ils seront
fiers la viande bien dans l'alcool bien
accueilli par des connexions très fort
chez lee très très dangereux s'est dit
très très dangereux enfin je ne me
trompe pas tiens plus pin à tort contre
le gaffeur fou mais il en existe plein
bitstream des deux côtés mais dont la
française on va rentrer des changes il
est sympa copine à tort tu le connais en
fait d'accord on l'a vu à paris et tout
mais j'imagine je le connais sa charte
lui le patron il y très grosse victoire
des noirs dans la partie précédente
c'est vrai que vous grosse partie de
rivedoux quoi baïla il ay là il a bien
égalisé avec les noirs et puis voilà
quoi le pin à tort qu'il faut que tu
oublies non mais aussi un pack tous les
pseudos quoi
ouais c'était triste ouais c'est
vraiment triste franchement oublier pour
le film à tort ça se fait pas quoi mais
très marrant ça fait marrer toute la
soirée il vraiment très drôle après faut
croire que c'est tabou fine à tort en
sueur bien sûr que je l'oublié donc il
veut je me rappelle de lui pour me oui
le mec s'est laissé faire froid de satin
voilà bien sûr je me souviens pas des
comme ça il doit pas y en avoir tant que
ça d'ailleurs bref la de l'acquis de
même rappelé bon goût il a su le fin mot
de s'asseoir et allons toujours pas faim
je ne réponds c'est fini il est
blacklisté ouais non mais ça c'est
extraordinaire histoire et une en
ajustant a appelé hier au téléphone on
discute un peu et en fait il se rappelle
pas de ce qu'il a fait pendant encore
huit ou neuf heures je me réveille chez
moi plus s'est il passé quoi bon j'étais
tout seul déjà pourquoi c'est beau quoi
ça il pourrait tellement correct c'est
tellement sa vie les machins de las
vegas à comment s'appellent les cons la
gamme bad trip
very bad trip web mais en fait very bad
trip sont très heureux de leurs
batteries plomb ouais c'est un truc
exceptionnel en fait au delà de son
quotidien et poivre à dégage chaque jour
j'ai ce problème
non mais j'adore le barbu codevi ap 10h
et s'appelait est marrant c'est un génie
qu'est ce qu'on dirait forexpo avec vlad
souvent ça marche pas son truc c'était
par m6 et chaque science était bien
français dont ils goûtent égale siro
demain pas vraiment le truc différent et
ouais bon ben c'est comme ça mais du
coup en faisant gaffe ça va bien voyez
pas c'est pas très dangereux en soi mais
n'a oublié prend f6 échec c'est normal
sinon c'est un sacrifice de dames
ingénieux c'est ingénieux mais pas mal
joué les blancs il a bien voulu prendre
la colonne aussi avant tout ça
richesse comme gratuit mois ils ont
redémarré le dos parfois malheureusement
de désolé réf
c'est de revenir après mais du coup je
suis pro des rentes de retraite ça dur
de gagner
j'espère que ça sera en fait j'ai des
infos que je peux pas dire je m'en
donnait juste un tout petit peu mais il
ya des arenas à très bientôt revenir
avec un nouveau format etc
et j'espère que tu auras réussi à régler
ce tu croyais mais là c'est ouais ils
ont dû redémarrer le serveur il ya un
truc qui a dû à pipi saout
ouais mais le problème c'est que en fait
du coup il ya un gros afflux
d'utilisateurs du combat les gens sont
chez eux et bien il faut avoir les
serveurs solide et que tout marche bien
et il n'ya pas que ça est aussi
généralement sur internet plus de gens
je crois non ça crée un peu d mais il se
bat font un pin à thoiry et trouver du
jeu quoi bella satouri réception il est
là qu elle moins 40 en deux parties ça
fait plaisir mais ça fait un peu mal
mais bon forçant ces derniers n'arrivent
à quoi moi aussi j'en ai perdu 40
le tout en deux trois parties mais moi
c'est par bribes aux siens sa salle fait
puis après ça ça marche
la capote masqué qui veut avoir le lien
je lance aux obsèques
mais tous bis et elles ont battu pour le
final pas je suis patient après à deux
dames 1 et 3
je suis macho sapeurs dont on leur
annonce aussi sûrement mais a juste pour
montrer ce que c'est intéressant
genre tu fais ça ça et ça m'a plus
grande valeur
alors après est-ce que ok tu peux pas
passer sur cette diagonale par contre
mais bon au pire tu pourra enlever la
toile j'ai rien je suis pas sûr qu'ils
soient perdants loin d'être sûr ça des
coûts d'attendre de partout gens comme
quoi tu as quoi que il peut essayer ce
qui peut essayer de bosser un peu mais
bon
peut-être que ton roi il venir rang des
6 et 7 ulcéré cinq fours à assumer cinq
tours à 4 safar murs non mais laurent fc
après avec les blockbusters g5 comprend
on reprend miro 5 est versé 6
mais bon en tout cas c'est clair c'est
une folie tant que ça c'est dommage
parce qu'il avait il a renvoyé le jeu
n'attend pas ça fait mal c'est avoir des
gens qui se baladent avec une dame de
moins tu as qui abandonne pas ça avant
comme trop généralement bas ça dépend ça
peut être une stratégie intéressante
dans l'aréna parce que tu as marqué plus
de points niveau ont perdu pour perdu
j'abandonne leur joie ouais
après oui c'est système suisse ou quoi
vous jouez bercé l'erreur de pupi poupe
hier quatre obus s'accrocher dans des
parties ouais mais il n'avait pas capté
le constat marché encore les arènes a
maintenant 17
il fallait que je me renseigne toi oui
pourquoi tu n'as pas gagné 10 quines toi
je fais mon métier afu pense qu'il y
avait des joueurs très forts ont fait
que gagner y avait en fait émincé et
anne qui a gagné hier
ok mais ok dangereux et âme quand même
face et pas n'importe qui peut y
atteindre dans son somptueux ses bananes
vertes
non mais il est dangereux il est bon en
aréna je vais tellement battu en finale
qu'il a bossé ces finales mais
maintenant il faut pas mal en finale
donc il bâille laraque et ja on a
défoncé la terre-battue rossi voilà ils
se disent s'y perd et apple s'était dit
cette baston soutien de radjabov où nous
ne jouerons pas non plus voyons le
rabâche marcher dessus c'était c'était
mais bon le perron qui sera beaucoup
plus fort dimanche prochain il va
falloir s'accrocher qui est des frères
corrie je sais pas qui font sourire mais
ils ont des mecs fort qui participent
épervier dont quelques bons joueurs
on sent qu'ils ont un niveau général
assez fort de ce que je vois sur thiès
comme et dans les arènes
enfin dans les matchs je te connais mais
n'ont pas volé leur ceviche très bon
aussi il faut dire avec à farfouiller
dame prend tournure qu on tienne la
chance des sourds garde on regarde chef
ce que tu veux mais jeff qu'elle jeff
jeff mutuel à midi à lyon 6 600 n'aime
pas ça mais en l'occurrence et 5 quoi
voilà c'est bon ou pas c'est étonnant ce
avec beaucoup de joueurs démarrent comme
ça parce que bon déjà il faut un truc
bien ce qui se développe sortante
cavaliers et prennent le sens donc c'est
pas catastrophique mais contrairement à
eux quatre cinq ouvertures quand il ya
des cap des 5 s'est mieux dire des
séries de la dame soit pour venir en 17
soit en c6 si vous faites c'est ça donc
ça en est cette phase que va faire les
plans en fait avec les crayons des deux
soit avec les purs ans et 6 avec le pion
à ses cinq lieux parce que ça a l'air
plus le jeu la dame peut sortir
on doit développer outre que [ __ ] case
manche qui est pas terrible la tour pour
annoncer 8 et la colonne s'ouvrir alors
que la l1 peut donc ça offre plus de
possibilités
cependant la cif et 5 a aucun problème
il aura quelque part justifié son
cavalier la justification mais c'est
bien joué quand même un la part de jeff
stratégiquement tu as vu il s'est remis
sur ses pieds bel effort gev hp dit que
ça a joué bien notre eh bien non mais
c'est bien stratégiquement de comprendre
le truc de fer 1,5 et où nous en bus
c'est bien parce que le chou bah du coup
il peut espérer sortir
quand les arénas plus ou moins je suis
pas dire bon une fourchette d'ici six
mois quoi ok je peux dire une franche
normale en avril pour chat je peux dire
d'ici fin avril
on sait pas quand même d'accord j'avais
cru comprendre que c'était fin mai a
alors ça devait être début mai mais ça
devait être ouais ça devait être début
mai mais ça va être ça va être pour
avril mais ce serait bien
moi ça fera d'animation des trous d'eau
s'écoule bien plus tôt possible mais je
peux aussi dire un truc sans dévoiler
forma d'accor ne voulait suis
complètement contre le nouveau format
des arrêts de jeu peut déjà dire que je
vais gueuler parce que c'est ce qui je
suis complètement contre leur feu le
nouveau format sans dire pourquoi encore
qu'est-ce qu'ils allaient peu avec
l'ancien je peux te dire qu'au vu du
nouveau format l'ancien était parfait et
pourtant j'ai gueulé contre l'ancien on
va découvrir ça avec elle je peux te
dire que ça va rage et que ça va
insulter des mers et que c'est ça va
être absolument n'importe quoi mais
c'est vous en fait on est toujours reine
je paye je passe ici les recourants de
ce truc
non j'en suis très très content la
dernière saison a été plus grave au
niveau des horaires en revanche vrai
mais franchement quand vous allez bon
quand je pourrai parler de nouvelles
règles
vous allez voir que c'est vraiment de la
merde ce que je veux 4 heures du matin
attention dame et sa part affecté son
vrai nom c'est vraiment le format obligé
de jouer sur l'échiquier en 3d ou si tu
veux que je te le disent parce je peux
couper les micros
non je veux dire toi plutôt non moi du
terme et moi tu pourras non ok on fait
un truc vraiment dans le délire bouchez
vous les oreilles
non on coupe les micros je te dis et tu
confirmes no fake que c'est vraiment de
la merde oui mais comment tu comme le
microscope sur la suite mon temps je te
dis le fort de nouveaux formats et judy
no fake c'est vraiment format de merde
et là je comprends pas frais laférois eu
de hockey allez c'est parti on coupe les
micros
donc femme maintenant que tu as entendu
le nouveau format est ce que tu peux
confirmer que c'est de la merde
e
ouais ouais je pense un diction sens
ordinance pas possible j'ai coupé elite
soul et desvres on est d'accord c'est
vraiment fort mal merde pas bah non pas
le fruit face et en tunisie qui est pas
terrible dans le truc c'est beau quand
tu prouves le no fake
ja je prouve là je je je confirme que
après après j'ai quand même fait un
retour pour leur dire que c'est un
format de merde donc peut-être que on va
m'écouter quoi je ne sais pas c'est
génial pavant sur aussi rare que tu
joues pas ou quoi mais non je veux
enlever ça tu as gagné un surnom je te
dis comment c'est possible dans la série
donne en fait je compte baa doit non
plus ça prouve le no fake à 100% quand
même femme confirme s'il s'en va à lens
mais bon en tout cas dans cette partie
intéressante le roi est parti on sait
pas trop si c'est possible de partir ok
mais les blancs ne sont pas pleutre et
veulent attaquer la prison la seconde
attention toutefois si un petit fou un
f5 quand même ce serait pas mal non pour
défendre cette clou le cavalier seul en
face du roi bons offices bien aussi
battant est-ce que damages 5 est ce que
je gagnais pas on ne sait pas mais grâce
à kaunas rien non mais défendre
cavaliers king atteint mais on verra ça
fait mal
les est dommage elliott parce qu'en fait
c'est beaucoup mieux ta dépendre plus et
pour mettre en place tout seul en
voulant attaquer alors que tu peux faire
que tu iras tu crois qu'à id3 tu finis
pour développement et tu va la gagner
long terme
en voulant attaquer comme ça bon je
trouve ça marche pas mais en plus tu
laisses ça me parle d'un serti dans la
partie est ce que j'aime bien ce qu'ils
sont pas pleutre qua non ça ça va une
pièce de plus de plus en plus on en rien
à [ __ ] quoi les gars je t'attaque
pourra quand même je suis fils une tour
dégage je pense que le mec avec les
noirs jeff va pas être
plus enfin ils vont pas te faire des
petits des échanges de damous quoi
tomber autant retombée trois maires marc
est en fait le point c'est bien peut
être le truc quoi mais je pense c'est de
faire trop d'exercices tactique où tu
vois toujours des sacrifices et que ça
m'as tu ne s'arrête jamais dans la vraie
vie
jamais ça tue à conduire une partie de
temps en temps comme ça mais c'est tout
la plupart du temps c'est faut être
pragmatique et savoir gagner une finale
avec un compte plus ses finales de roi
comme ça ouais il est donc de sens je
suis pas pour faire trop tactique
d'exercice de machin c'est bien un peut
éveiller les sens tactique voire contre
une combinaison une attaque pourquoi
mais la plupart du temps ces séances en
cela que le puzzle rush il est pas si
mal je trouve ce que tu as beaucoup de
tactique vraiment genre une pièce
emprise en un une
une enfilade tu as beaucoup de trucs
comme ça qui sont pas des sacrifices en
fait une fourchette à 1
et ça c'est pas mal dans le puzzle match
c'est que tu as vraiment beaucoup de
choses réalistes
non mais genre si tu vois ce que
monsieur foot je vois que des vidéos de
retourner tout le temps tout le temps et
dès que tu as gold fin retournacois mais
on a juste eu à jamais marqué à mi temps
on est retombé enfin un an ta vie quoi
mais oui le ballon et enfin si tu as du
solde de sa grosse journée quand même
enfin s'il faut que dans un cadre bien
précis que mal face à la force de
l'amitié peut gagner un peut-être n'en
oui c'est vrai mais on voit bien
développer la force de l'amitié avant de
finir tiens regarde de calage peut-être
greffe aulaye contre elliott est ce que
idiote va pouvoir après sa vie à 100
on vient de le regarder mourir est ni
blancs et les noirs ouais mais vous
d'être homo greffe aulas qui eux
attendent un coup les locaux pas juste
en est ce qu'il va pouvoir s'en sortir
tu penses tu as eu peu il est sur la
peur de sa vie là le mec à plus du
double de points de lui ouais je pense
souvent des six plutôt que à 6 mai un
second mandat s'en faut pas faire des 5
voilà une notion d'art au clan à la
criée à six manches de la me prend ok on
a vu se peut sur l'autre jour avec le
pion aux simples bilan des six ce qui
est un peu moins bien pour les normandes
pour heureusement parce que t'as pas de
9,6 par tüv est en vie mais pas ou fait
du coup cette chiant de rock et toutes
les finales sont moins bonnes et trop
sûr il faut être quatre ou quoi qu'il
arrive et défendent la dame sud profond
des six il est bien placé ne faut pas
trop regarder l'épisode d'olive et tom
sens tu ne seras jamais mais c'est un
peu pareil en fait assez beau quand il
m'a carrément les matchs fait refaire
les tirades charles de gaulle est grosse
et de rebondir sur le poteau pour prend
pas refaire la pulsion tu vas relais
mckenzie qui grimpe au poteau pour être
bien pour les corner la catapulte
[Rires]
c'est ridicule c'est comme chaline
soccer welch allyn ce cas voilà ils font
des seuls trouvant le bon pour attaquer
ben voilà aussi qui tape dans le ballon
et le déforme la jeunesse prenant la
tête il voulait bien aussi le cas depuis
la toile mais aussi de ne pas parler
mais je vais laisser à sa cause du corps
à cette malédiction une bénédiction
ouais bon là cette année tu as été une
souffrance de voir les matches mais on
n'est pas sorti d'affaires un peu
vouloir reprendre la saison donc non pas
reprendre bas ils ont tous envie parce
que je crois que financièrement ils ont
besoin pour les clubs de foot et ce
depuis que canal + hier ou avant-hier a
annoncé qu' ils paient plus droits télé
ça fait mal ouais ça pourrait être un
manque à gagner sur la fin de saison
je crois de 190 millions d'euros quand
même bon après je comprends que tu vas
payer droit sont des matchs que tu as
peut diffuser à bah oui mais je pense
que le sait cette crise elle va
fondamentalement est profondément changé
l'économie du sport ou y avait
énormément d'argent c'était devenu
complètement n'importe quoi et je pense
que ça va ça va être serré mais je pense
non je passe mon métier serait pas plus
malin sur le fond moi je pense à lui
changé l'économie tout pour le tout mais
et pour le coup le sport way et mais
pour le coup ce soir si vous voulez voir
des match de st etienne ils vont nous
mettre la rediff de saint-etienne contre
kiev sur lcp la chaîne parlementaire tu
vois tes demande qu'à rien à parlementer
tiens regarde toi c'est une pièce 76
assez beau match ça ouais je ne ferai
pas le score bon moi je sais juste le
match aller il ya eu 2 0 pour kiev voilà
ce match retour à geoffroy guichard
après midi la mode kiev on et qui
préférait rester matuidi n'est vraie
grosse équipe vaste et légumes bio assez
sombre ouais avec l'entrée à l'heure de
génie mais bono sq de débats 9,6 ouais
il leur a tout appris
tout le football italien vient de lui en
fait il faut le savoir veille mais genre
toi t'es con reçu tu rigole car au
contraire en fait sans lui il n'y a pas
de football italien
oui mais bon je n'ai aucune culture donc
aller à fond on peut nous expliquer que
l'italien j'ai été champion du monde
deux semaines on est 30 alors non non
c'était déjà lui on vient jouer qui est
des 4 as le fourbe et cette contre
attaque le feu deux du côté du fou prend
des cinq qui peut traîner les trucs
comme ça moi franchement je trouve que
les gars qui ont qui ont mille mille
cent mille deux cent quatre trous à
jouer ils ont quand même des sacrés
bazinet
après ça y'a trop de scories dans leur
jeu mais je trouve que ça joue pas mal
tiens mais en regard du coup on
compterait à suivre maugréer contre
bitstream 717 camara donc bon beckham
clairement pour le mec qui arrive noir 1
à 6 contre 6 500 nageurs sont des 126 un
peu bizarre
il en train de faire mon truc son sac à
main l'uruguay a autant de coupes du
monde que la france on n'a pas une coupe
du monde puisque l'uruguay basons notre
santé comment expliquer que l'union
soviétique n'est jamais gagnée mondial
de foot c'est vrai salaire bas sont nuls
mais c'était pas si mauvais non non
c'est vrai mais c'est dur dynamique
voulue monde en fait t'as beau et fort
pouvoir un peu de chance mais il était
plus fort que manon l'union soviétique
oui oui l'argent déjà il était grand que
le rsa mais il avait un gardien de but
de génie dans away yashin ouais ouais de
fantastique idée fantastique il a eu le
ballon d'or c'est le gardien de
l'histoire avant une belle était
extraordinaire ouais donc là le problème
c'est la casse des six pour les noirs
auraient pu pousser minutes 66 voir
aujourd'hui ne sais pas pour encore nous
rejoindre l'urss pas ou fort mais je
crois que c'est une équipe puisque
c'était pas mal de postes et puis c'est
comme la tchécoslovaquie qui aurait pu
aussi gagner en jeu puis la hongrie avec
l'équipe de bob de puskas
tchécoslovaquie ces bois 62 c'est en
finale
j'espère qu'on a fait pour se retrouver
de coupe du monde mais là on fait on est
hyper fort depuis 98 pas mais mon revers
depuis les années 80 globalement parce
que demi-finale 92 dans l'usiné 86 du
passage à vide pas de coupe du monde 90
94 98 vainqueur en 2002 prs mais on a
une équipe pour gagner
si zidane est pas blessé ou quoi tu
enfin les pires est fait les croisés
avant fin aux quais on peut toujours
refaire le monde avec des si mais bon
sang et des années pires ses shows 2006
final on peut gagner coiffe un ça va et
bah là on a regagné en 2018 le rôle
était finaliste fins et la france depuis
20 ans c'est pas mal mais bon avant
pendant 50 ans rien du tout trois demi
finales quand même mais même punch
finalement on a une plus belle équipe
qu'aujourd'hui tester bien jouer fouet
trois pour gagner à cazères et on et
platine et où quand on est des bons
joueurs ah ouais petit knees par là je
pense qu'on a gagné sans avoir de
joueurs de génie brembo pays fait mal
ouais mais par un génie non il a un
génial il court vite mais je danse passe
mal ce cahier des six beaucoup trop fort
n'a pu y avoir quoi
griezmann pas mal mais pareil oui c'est
pas du yacht latine zidane mais s'est il
fait du bien à une équipe
en dominant n'est pas super fort non
plus franchement non mais pas trop de
points faibles quoi dire que bon lloris
je n'ai pas été très bon on était
meilleur que d'habitude se trouve au
goal défense solide bon varane très bien
bon après normalement il fallait que pas
avare arrière droit ce qui est arrivé
mais bon mieux défensif c'était pas mal
quand tu es enfant tu essaies phare
aubois pas mal de fans bien bavé qui
courent vite mais ouais en fait c'est
plus un collectif quoi ça que se fait
pas rêver devant son équipe mais
finalement tu regardes 98 ce n'est pas
rêver de base mais c'était solide promu
west pas très bien de toi et que tu n'es
pas chez ka thématique intégrines
casiraghi comment les gosses où elle a
du coup on fait juste une matraque eu
bat encore une caisse de bus moi c'est
quand même très bien pour les blancs
mais c'est pas encore gagné
tandis qu'à new york le roi manière
structure mais vrai non plus c'est bon
bon sur mon pauvre mais du coup ils
rataient le coche un peu avec les blancs
on va voir si il va quand même
l'emporter ou quoi c'est pas dit des
soupers sativa arriver attention un g2
ouais j'ai pas tué plus tôt à f3 non ici
comme tu as plus de foot cases blanches
des deux trophées unfp
on va perdre la dame côté blanc ouais
c'est ce qu'on regarde les parties au
hasard je vois c'est que choisir vient
de commencer en vrai donc bon pas tout à
fait fini encore femmes
non non non il faut s'accrocher
oui moi doublé tour on essaye un truc
d'hommes g5 arrive j'aime bien aussi
c'est une tour f ça je suis pas tu te
bats quoi il peut par ok c'est de vous
fâcher cette rente nan moi tout ça a été
ça se passe très mal
[Musique]
si tu fais là ramage faire éclore mais
en fait il a doublé son haut débit dont
il n'y a pas de grand âge il est
peut-être oublié qu'ils n'ont pas mieux
faire frange blonde kate ufferte être
toi j'ai cette frange de moindres de
brèves de bon qu'elle sera fait ce
travail te prends-tu je suis partant
vite on va plutôt pour des petites gens
mais tu cours s'ils voient ça ça fait
mal car ils devraient devoir peut-être
il l'a vu un celi détour g7 résister
pour pas à toi de ton rêve est à l'étude
pas assez puissant pour que ça c'est pas
fini il ya plus d'échecs et plus les
shégués succède à me très vite ça peut
être pénible
oui ça va encore il protège la tour m
peut-être va faire bouger 5
je mets à se battre quand même
ah oui mais là ça c'est pas de dommages
a infligé cinq ans plus tôt la polio
radama chiens de pure à tour élite oui
le double-double fois le même thème
ouais quand le roi par sur la première
tu prends un but de toi je suis trois
bouge tout reprend bas m'a aidé à me
prend 1,8 à des zoos qui chantait tout
le web je suis bien à deux vallées dit
qu'il pleuvrait qui aura de l'orage
aujourd'hui tout en fait il ya grand
soleil et les oiseaux son patch page
fois qu'ils sont très énervés ouvrir ma
jante 11,2 au chant des autres de faire
vos seulement ici non il fait gris
donner aux gens de voir 10 me disent
merde
après comme je disais les mouettes sont
très énervés badauds plonge je veux dire
les mecs vous plaît la bombe
la boulangerie il jette plus de pain ils
vont plus au mcdo enfin qu'est ce qu'on
fait ils ne vont plus au monde leur
petite glace
on est très mal quoi ça il faut que j'ai
fait un petit tour et c'est à athis sur
la planète en regarder la mer elle était
ça se faisait une grande ligne quoi
c'était dubitatif
ouais regarder la mer c'est oui bon on
va être obligé aller pêcher des poissons
tels fatigue je pense c'est très
énervant de pêcher quoi alors on peut
aller voir pato de chasse bastia 1905 la
ruine tout ci contre vive 72 ans à ses
systèmes de l'ombre détruisent ses shows
des minorités fessé 5-1 rapidement d'une
particule voilà c'est bien mais ça c'est
bien ce qui fait vivre
j'aime bien c'est du grand classique
n'en brosse très bon système pon bon je
vais changer d'amis c'est ça tu nous
faire dame c'est tout un truc comme ça
tu vas essayer à 6
ouais faut calculer peut-être mesdames
sa tanière cool si tu fais autour des 8
tu as this sargeras qu'elle est là et
ensuite bas soit on verra mais ça aussi
non tu y avait eu quatre français
enlevés le cas d'ali effet rex avec
autour des 8 tout cas pas de souci
plaindre mais l avantage pour les gens
c'est que même en jouant ce qui a élevé
cinq batteurs rient plus garder une
position solide la pâte arrivé un truc
trop grave
john a eu envie de le prendre je ferme à
mener si j'aimerais mais j'ai pris je
voulais pas de défaite immédiate une
preuve du ksar au dessus
le problème c'est qu'il ya ça qui rôdent
ya ça qui rôde un petit jamais bon pour
les noirs de voir cette structure avec
ses sept à huit a pu [ __ ] cases
blanches quand même et la bonne can
follow cavaliere il doit trouver 6,6 le
clip devrait donc pas mal de défauts
moment pour les noirs qui sont moins
bien qu'ils perdent à 6,72 tard
peut-être quatre pour bien garder destin
après tu vas jouer les pions quoi bonne
lecture à 5 pour la daf ou des 5 pouces
et 6 pas de trop de problèmes et apple
attaques habituelles sur le droit tu vas
souffrir
moi je pense plutôt malin ce qui fait
deux fils et une fille on est d'essayer
de nombreux livres
je suis comme toi quand tu sembles ici
un gars qui me fait ça je suis très
énervé on veut la dame doublés triplés
tour tout seul comme détroit de marie
jeanne la meuse
si toutes les attaques qui tour ces
trois offres
ces trois trous doublé de plus qu'au
lycée j'ai un peu une pierre deux coups
il joue pas mal a pas trop pataud de
chasse ouais ouais non mais ça a des
avantages du système de l'undd en fait
c'est un jour du coup simple soit on
sait pas membre
j'ai besoin de trop se casser la tête
après oui comme elle a franchement au
début il avait bien joué avec les nerfs
ça allait très bien ce qui les fait mes
cahiers 17 a tout remis en question
malheureusement mais pour ça que c'est
pas un mauvais choix pratique pour les
blancs parce que au fait tu fais tes
premiers coups assez tranquille déjà
mais moins bien au pire tu te fait
égaliser puis tu joues une partie que
t'as pas besoin d'apprendre trop de
théorie est ce que je veux moi mr ouai
mais d'autres différends sur des quatre
des cinq sur des 4e 6e patronne ou non
non je préfère faire flouer 5
c'est fort j'ai tout le temps des
poubelles
elle choque la honte avec des sacs très
pénible oui parce que papa mais alors là
c'est le va-tout total mais bon moment
ça peut mener bien je sais qu'il allait
faire [ __ ] 6 pour essayer de prendre
du fouet
au total et ça peut marcher ouais bah
tant pis on fait ce mois-ci c'est pas
terrible je ne sais pas encore
il l'a pas vu mais bon il me la sucent 5
f6 peut-être dame g7 qui va arriver mais
bon vu trois châteaux rien se défend h4
g3 se défend la même froid tout simple
si un joueur pareil que les noirs
comment tu crées des menaces
malheureusement n'ont donc fait pas
défaut au pot de fer rouge et 5h 4 et
jouer sur l'autre aile un peu on sent
bon le fauchage des cons je vais faire
quelque chose c'est pas mal insanités
sait pas mettre dans l'idée maison qu'il
dit 1,8 pour cette tâche devos belle
partie stratégique pour le moment c'est
foutu fait les notes du tournoi la fin à
toutes les parties un battant c'est pas
fini ma se voir si photoshop ou lala sa
tâche était 8 fois la stratégie mais là
la sfic maso vienne tu as été un chat
noir voudra pour pas trop chez le chat
noir quoi c'est horrible le mec n'avait
rien demandé et maazou est venu coiffer
invitons de nordine attention et tout
s'écroule à une partie digne de suta ce
qui est dommage c'était il avait bien
jouer sa partie pauvre pas atteint je
suis ne rien demander à personne il va
se retrouver contre maso lui faire un
procès oui je vous demande pas un
trillion m à landivy les choix qui
touche 12 tonnes gauche défend tout
miceli s'infiltrant la pression adverse
et sert à quoi tient ce week-end pas
trop tard pour rejoindre le tournoi non
au contre leur entrée après l'abandon
vraiment tu vas peut-être pas le gagner
ça peut partir tard mais tu peux jouer
quel moment voilà le lien dans le chat
le week-end prochain
tu vas jouer avec le contre le pérou
alors tu nous rejoint ben c'est comme
ouais je sais pas encore la date sera
sûrement dimanche 20h samedi 21 non je
veux tu peux jouer le bullet au un noir
ça va être beau qu'on va aller défoncer
hartung qui va venir rares puppy poupe
ça me l'a dit qu'ils jouent et toi
peut-être corner tofas serait
fantastique collègue laura et comprendre
quoi mais aussi well as the sera
fantastique en red lights on va dégager
et péruviens qu'on veut plus voir google
quoi vous l'at on range étroit ça fait
mal avec le clouage bien je lis aziz et
maquis très heureux qu'ils divergent sur
twitch equidia la chaîne youtube a juste
montré il est maso qui était pas mal
base et voulait faire à froid je crois
levy découragement et ahmed cissé
perpète débat il ya un petit piège mais
c'était pas idiot c'était pas idiot oui
je vais je vais quand même lui met huit
malgré tout pour la pour le pour le
moment stratégique de la partie voilà
d'être 5 vous avez 1 4 alors c'est quoi
cette partie mais tu vois c'est çà ou là
c'est ça qui est cru à nos échecs c'est
que je veux faire une très bonne partie
en fait je fais une erreur et ça c'est
fini tu peux alors qu'au tennis tu es
une balle dehors ça va bien mais je
disais le jour oui mais avec une fois tu
dis souvent ce qui est du don qui joue
ta petite vente de la carte jeune avec
les nex et 5
d'autant oiseaux sont menacés ou c'est
un art si si c'est pareil
ces derniers se prononce à l'italienne
ou à la langue quoi maze en italien
sûrement
nombreux en effet nord c'est bien ce
qu'il fait ouais il avait structure
française il a sorti son fouet la casse
et le centre et wc d'attaqué au sol
j'imagine c'est ricardo à 668 qu il est
chaud mais s'écarte pas mal aussi bien
joué mais le cleach c'est direct le
combat
les fous les blancs la berd bauer le
jeune passeur d'âmes c3 qui pourrait
être une bonne idée mais trois paires
fouchou quand même il a perdu son pion
central et à faire en terme n 2 a plus
de pions centraux après niveau c'est dur
quand c'est comme ça en général
y a plus qu'à se développer et rauque et
pousser les pions et je voulais leur
effet sur sur cinq il fait pas un peu
plus tôt des six what i ve webo 5 c'est
bizarre tout ça mais c'est comme si on
me fait des quatre enfants et on attend
maintenant parce que le 5 non plus une
cible et six sur des sites e prends tu
peux prendre et sur des 4 8 et 5 par
exemple tu as l'impression à une
position symétrique tout à gagner à caen
un ouais c'est une trop grande des
changes accessible maintenant vous savez
les blanquetiers fait 6 3 après tu peux
aussi faire dame prend des 6es jeune
scandinave dame décide avec ces sites
sont plus c'est au tour d'amd cinquième
des six étapes et en mai puis 5 juin
gane timing plus de temps batta ses six
plus fut adapté c'est ce que tu écris
ces trois séances hors à toi de jouer
bon du coup on ne peut pas glisser trois
mais wayne décisif on sait très bien qu
il se bat peut changer
on voit très peu trop je te ferai du fou
b4g changera tout joué en finale
heureusement que tu vous passez 3
c'est quand même problématique serait
pas le beau jeu
vous pensez quoi du petit mot rizzi
peut-il devenir un top blanc les années
à venir
oui peut-être que non tant sur les rails
en fait mais ne peut passer du retrait
annoncé en fait mais il joue très bien
il est très fort par son âge après tu
sais je sois c'est plein de choses tu as
de progresser il faut deux choses que je
ne sais pas en fait non tu sais on se
bat non mais personne chaque nuit je
vais marizy en glisse j'ai perdu d'un
coup qui perd 2,6 normal même des fois
quand c'est pas en blitz arrive de
perdre cas pas de masque et qu'on garde
son ouverture mais à ckoi son pseudo
contre jean fut ni jouer c'est à yu-hwan
machin swiffer jean [ __ ] le voilà tout
il faut tout ça est la pincée d'avant
c'est pas facile de revenir en partie
précédente des gens croient que nous
raconte juste un look à une question sur
la langue grand prix de la sicilienne
madidi nous si on peut t'aider mais
veine on le dit dans le petit mort dit
c'est un des plus grands espoirs
français
m la grand prix qu'on puisse lui
répondre
ses amis a pas de question votre qu'est
ce qu'on en pense bas c'est très jouable
c'était mugler dépollution un peu pour
attaquer ou quoi vas-y c'est assez
violent et si elles ne réagissent mal
ils auront des problèmes et même s'ils
réagissent mal ce n'est pas d'hier sera
moins bien que les blancs tu peux tu
peux te faire plaisir ce que tu vas bien
ou non c'est pas mal s'il aime fermé ça
va aussi
en fait toutes les deux fait qu'on dira
tous les deux artères sont jouables faut
juste pas jouer des trucs trop grotesque
4 à 6 ou je sais pas quoi
les grands moments désolé mais
mais si vous êtes né entre l'ouverture
qui est un peu joué par les joueurs pas
mal ça va
la grotte jusqu'à un certain niveau ça
passe voilà jusqu'à champion du monde ça
veut passer après après quand les gens
commencent vraiment à savoir jouer hélas
si jeune cavalière 3 c'est intéressant
ou pas ouais mais bon ça je vais vous
dire non mais en fait oui mais non c'est
déjà faut comprendre pourquoi tu le fais
parce qu'en fait de bas salaires bizarre
que vaille au bord tu développes
vaguement mais du coup c'est que tu
demandes aux noirs jouer un coup tu veux
un truc utile tu gardes le ces trois des
quatre c'est déjà un peu trop
sophistiqué quoi tu vois c'est un peu
comme faire une française avec h 6 au
troisième coup de 4,6 d4 d5 qu'edel ok
j'arrête
si ce n'est même pas con quoi mais il
faut comprendre pourquoi tu fais si tu
fais ça c'est grotesque qui se
développerait j'ai passé 5 qui fait donc
ça je fais pas le con c est la sienne
3 pourquoi pas c'est grotesque non moins
fameux de four b2 contre une bonne
diagonale qui développe le faire à
quatre voies bas ils tiennent que j'aime
bien aussi pour les gens qui savent pas
ce pourquoi j'ai bon ça marche que sur
des six malheureusement c'est qu'elle ne
coule plus jouer ces salles où tu prends
avec la dame je trouve ça assez facile à
jouer d'abord comment quand tu écris
c'est situe le coup tu le bouffer tu
développes tps bêtement quoi je trouve
qu'elle est assez simple à jouer même en
bustier du venin émission est très
venimeux 6e foule n'en peut plus
d'attendre j'ai jamais trop regarder
mais chaque c'est pas idiot mais c'est
un peu une sorte de grand prix foued web
sont battus à agen les noirs ils vont
faire enfin qui sait s'ils sont à dire
tu vas faire f 4g pas coup kf3 des trois
épis dames battue rhodes et d'un match 4
et 5 et fois je sais c'est basique comme
plan b en fait pourquoi pas si énorme
même temps me david lucas et des cas tu
crois toujours fous d un éléphanteau les
presser 3 6 3
bah ouais tu arrives à que c'est un peu
une ça me fait penser en fait à ce que
simone williams syrie joue à une époque
sur tessa hollandaise et noir et sauf
que tu as les pions en
plus bas tous métayer pleureuses et
arrive à ça donc c'est déjà ce que tu as
envie de faire et la stella match 4 voit
très bien la lapine stratégiquement
c'est bien tu prends 200 mais en fait qu
aujourd hui j ai fait tout est bien
passé
normalement il n'ya aucune ouverture qui
va réfuté ce que très rares jours
jurassienne s'est pas réputés mous vous
choisissiez n'importe quoi à tout va
mais il faut s'y tenir comprendre
pourquoi vous jouez ce à suivre les
plans intéressants bien placer vos cassé
puis voilà bien comme il faut quoi bien
comme il faut on attend on va voir qui
le charlatan contre ludovic pakhtunkhwa
kf3 détroit effet une attaque à
saint-yan actuellement les noirs ou le 5
à suzuka et ses 6 2 et 6 3 je veux 5
d'ailleurs pour les noirs normalement
c'est mieux de pas faire payer si ce
soit comme toi tu es sur la pire attaque
et fayçal est jusqu'à un meilleur
contrôle du centre ils tuent bloque pas
la vision de tonton g7 c'est pas la fin
du monde de faire ça mais n'appartient
pas à cette hausse à 7,4
je vois que tu es là tu as étudié mes
parties ah oui jouer comme lui très
intéressant c'est pas mal ce système
avec le cas à eux deux quais c3 est très
solide
tu prends le centre et ça va très
logique et ses héros
en gros pour vous dire oui vous choisir
n'importe quelle variante que vous
voulez dans les ouvertures mais il faut
juste le faire de manière logique et pas
jouer les kwasa ouais bah là mais j'ai
fait ce que je vaux hasard finalement
c'est pas le nom mais normalement il
doit un peu avoir étudié connaître les
plans ça va aimer que le cas j'attends
qu'ils aident les pièces qu il te dit
comment trouver les plans d ouverture
mais il faut regarder partout tu vas pas
les inventer en fait pour garder les
parties anciennes comment les mecs ont
joué commencé à évoluer vers l'histoire
c'est du boulot un peu où sont gravés
hnb stream des fois on voit des réponses
atteint les plans là mais ça doit
arriver en vrai t'as des playlists sur
la chaîne si on regarde les temples et
elissa les piètres playlist par
l'ouverture après pas par variante parce
que parce qu'on fait
ça a été un peu compliqué mais tu peux
regarder sparrow ouverture et tu peux
vite
enfin si tu fais le boulot ton côté tu
peux tu peux tu peux t'isoler les
variantes que tu aimes sur sur les
ouvertures pas c'est ça et puis même les
vidéos qu'on fait des votes le prendre
de trois notes dire oui ça c'était bien
c'était pas bien puis tu compile tu fais
avec une autre une autre une autre un
moment matane tasset de matériel puis
voilà mais ouais en fait comme si on les
achète et un monde se demande un peu de
boulot oblige et malheureusement mais
bon comme un peu pour tous moi j'arrête
là encore faux procès non mais ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'on peut prendre ça
pour du boulot ou pas mais jarre même tu
vois si tu veux cuisiner un truc au
hasard il avoue quand même d'exercer un
peu coupé tes légumes palmer pas trop
mal savoir les dosages gratter une photo
de ta recette après tu y as we
j'améliore c'est vrai que j'arrive à
faire ça je prends des notes
tu peux acheter un livre de cuisine edit
ah oui mais avec ça a fait mal tu peuple
c'est du travail ou juste une sorte de
passion t'aime bien est améliore un peu
ce que tu fais tu deviens apache chef
étoilé pour autant mais juste si tu veux
te faire plaisir et invités du monde où
tu n'es pour toi bats et de le faire pas
trop mal moi je pense qu'après deux ans
tu peux avoir un niveau et 2 étoiles
michelin minimum si tu passes et un tout
petit peu moi même plus peut-être mais
voilà qu'on peut appeler ça du boulot
entre guillemets aux échecs ça va être
pareil tu peux te dire tiens bon bah là
j'ai perdu pourquoi toute la question de
l'abattage m'améliorer tu perds mais
différemment et puis au bout d'un moment
tu concerne peut bien maîtrisée quand ça
se passe quand on regarde un peu notre
conseil si vous des livres écrits ou des
vidéos ou puis s'améliore un peu ça va
pas te faire énormément de poids le
champion du monde ou quoi mais j'ai peur
de faire un peu plaisir et comprendre
bien ce que tu fais et innover en disant
tiens gesti des personnes à fait
pourquoi pas testé mais ce sera plus du
hasard
ce sera dommage
écoute du coup ça c'est ce que tu fais
quoi la cuisine
les échecs étaient partis améliorent non
plus grand chose pour progresser c'était
obligatoire en fait faut analyser faut
essayer de comprendre
tes défauts comment corriger et par
refaire en fait passer un peu courte
verte the arch
bah c'est comme dans la vie chez papa il
ya une porte qui fonce dedans eye-fi
tiré du reflet turf et tous les jours
tabib enfin normalement tu fais pas ça
en fait tu essaie de comprendre pourquoi
ça l'est parce que de la fois d'après la
porte tu attires raout foncé pousser non
mais je sais pas facile aux échecs tu
perds toujours pareil j'ai encore perdu
depuis le 5 mai ben oui un mouvement
réfléchi deux secondes quoi ouais mais
toi tu fais plus j'essaie de ne pas
donner mon option de cinq ans deux coups
non mais j'étais sale [ __ ] progresser
non plus quoi non mais j'essaye mais je
fais pas tout ce qu'il faut pouvoir
parce qu'en fait je fais un niveau pour
continuer progressivement à faire pas
mal d'efforts et c'est facile quand tu
es jeune que tu as beaucoup de temps
libre que t'as pas de responsabilité que
t'as pas à gagner ta vie
plein de choses comme ça la bomba je
dois donner des cours donc tu aimes
découvre tu travailles plus pour toi
vous fait pas mal de temps de faire des
vidéos j'ai fait les dvd les bons c'est
autant de temps de tapas pour contrer
donc c'est plus difficile si j'avais dix
heures par jour a consacré près de
nouvelles variantes pourra essayer mais
c'est un choix aussi enfin je suis
contraint de me plaindre quoi bon c'est
comme ça
il m'est donc ouais je pense pas je vais
beaucoup progressé dans ma vie encore
quand vous allez chez est ce que ta part
de régresser du coup non je pense à sa
maman ça me fera pas plaisir de jeu
trauma les quatre jours a plus du tout
envie quoi mais si je régresse ça fait
pas plaisir je te prépares tu es un peu
compétiteurs auront enfin c'est comme ça
mais tant que j'aurai un niveau à peu
près potable c'est moi
tu te sens règle et c'est là où ça
dépend des fois je joue mal ça m'énerve
mais c'est parfois remet en fait je
pense pas je plus mal maintenant qui dix
ans qui a dix ans en fout aussi way ou
le problème c'est qu'il fonce pas plus
mal joué mais comme faut beaucoup plus
travaillée ouverture et machin tu vois
mon amour sa pratique sans pour autant
être vraiment moins bon mais juste des
ventes que tu joues à l'époque comme
tout le monde y préparer contre alors
qu'à l'époque nous donc ça marche moins
bien mais c'est pas que je joue moins
bien passé ça a changé en fait ce qu'on
me demande donc à part ça influe sur les
résultats et donc maintenant faut
beaucoup plus très les ouvertures qu'à
une époque évidemment mais c'est dommage
ouais bah ouais bah c'est chiant c'est
comme ça c'est marrant on fait le début
de partie c'est tellement pas important
pendant longtemps donc temps enfin papa
important mais c'était tellement mineurs
entre guillemets ça influe est tellement
peu et aujourd'hui ça influe tellement
déjà battu voilà je lis toujours livre
de petrossian évidemment ce petit à
petit il jouait vraiment de la merde
mince ouverture aouita des des quatre
pieds 3 pouces et 5 e match et le fiston
fiche à toi mais il avait un très bon
feeling dans le jeu
calculez bien fait tout bien hyper fort
mais il n'était pas là te planter 35e
coup nouveautés de ci de ça et il n'y a
plus un et sa préparation c'était plutôt
justement comment piéger l'adversaire
par rapport à son style de jeu il
chercha à rentrer dans un style de
position qui l'aimé bien et que l'autre
allait être moins à l'aise c'était
c'était aussi c'était intéressant c'est
autre chose c'était plus de psychologie
je trouve mes deux plantes équitable y
aura soit un moment
hiram ça il va mal joué je me souviens
il avait déjà joué contre contre machin
cette partie très mal et c'était ça en
fait et puis fallait connaître les
parties alors vu en direct avoir pris un
crédit
ce n'est pas de bases de données je
connais tout le monde seuls oui mais
voilà tout ça ça disparaît bien sûr
maintenant en fait tu peut masquer des
vraies faiblesses dans le jeu par de la
préparation
et recopier les couleurs des cartes wa
même dans le fond tu comprends pas ce
que tu fais mais juste eu c'est leur
diaby et que c'est plus 0,50 donc
toujours étude des mecs fort toi dans le
fond comme ça moi c'est ce qui m'a un
peu trop nettement je suis franchement
envie d'arrêter les échecs il si dur en
fait rire pour te maintenir faut bosser
bosser bosser mais après c'est émotif
très bien enfin il donc aussi ça peut
être une occasion de devenir fort 11 ans
travaille donc c'est aussi assez
admirable les gens qui arrivent à le
faire et par exemple je sais pas c'est
pas manquer de respect à alger si tu es
un mec comme un dragueur du top niveau
je sais pas je trouve pas qu'ils jouent
hyper bien dans le fond une fête mais il
est plus ou moins de 1700 dans
l'ouverture tu vas pas la voir comme ça
il connaît tous très bien il a traversé
une de travail donc ce admirable de sa
part avait à faire ça juste parce que
j'admire le plus - en fait c'est ma fête
mais mais c'est possible en fait même
quasiment dans la 2007 sont comme ça je
pense après les gars c'est bon ils
arrivent à calculer je pense que
maintenant c'est très bon dans
l'ouverture et tu calcules bien bon déjà
des grands maîtres c'est sur eux mêmes
aléas 2007 du 27 30 40 comme navarre non
mais d'avoir à vous bientôt
on aime bien rigoler avec lui il ne
connaît rien tout ça mais non c'est
objectivement pour une fois j'ai bien
car objectivement s'ils connaissaient
mieux les ouvertures il pourrait
peut-être 27 67 79
comment ne pas connaître
là je me dis qu'un mec comme petrosur
maintenant je sais pas trop y seront
faites au maire de renwez champion du
monde tout cas mes chiens parce qu'il
aura 2007 devrait cartonner les
ouvertures dès qu'il voit son truc pour
égaliser en face ils auraient du mal à
mettre des points sera un peu p trop
chiant pour lui ben ils auraient dû se
réinventer en fait comme mai mais ce
style de jeu la plus dure 1
ouais non merde moi je trouve que c'est
face à une mutation des échecs que je
trouve un peu dommage je crois que
majorité qu'il ya plus de feeling tout à
l'heure dans le tchat
moi je dis que ça rend le jeu moins
intéressant mais après son personnel
pour le coup c'est pour ça aussi que je
pense que le jeu rapide ça peut sauver
un peu ce côté là aussi un mérite c'est
parce que ça ça va demeurer et battu peu
plus réussite et a même plus le temps de
te rappeler vraiment de tout site à
houla elle est aussi celle de pièces qui
viennent de cazaux mais oui tu va de
nouveau avoir le côté feeling qui va
encore prendre le dessus mais on voit
que dans la seine en bits s'il est
encore plus fort que les autres
sauf que maxime mais sinon on voit que
son feeling positionnelle il est
incroyable ouais je vous vite écarté de
fait tout bien fait un petit calcul
hyper bien et en plus c'est évidemment
une vaste culture et ce feeling et cette
compréhension qu'ils font qui vaille de
même pas besoin de trop de temps pour
prendre la bonne décision
marie l'impressionnant je trouve ça sera
encore plus envie ce que l'on croit oui
semble être en bitume et des fessées et
les parties bien construite c'est pas
juste qui est attaquée tu calcules
racheter maths c'est ouais ça fait grand
maître contre comme débutants et me
défends passer du 2007 ou pas mais je me
rappelle qu'il en avait mis une vraiment
sale au championnat du monde
blitz à cramique c'était un sursaut de
carlsbad normal juste système de monde
ouais ouais où il attaquait son roi pas
être mesquin c'était impressionnant face
à donner vraiment l'impression
par ce truc carlsbad c'est le truc le
plus classique entre guillemets de
l'école soviétique de great wall street
et en plus quand denis qui joue pas même
sa chronique s'annonce là dedans mais il
avait juste fin c'était un massage
extraordinaire en réalité est là il
s'est passé kramnik pour un amateur
quasiment et c'est incroyable je trouve
c'est un peu comme un extraordinaire
moi j'étais sur le cul franchement banon
ce parti et les vents violents
oui car actuelle du long et donc non
mais voilà enfin après bon bah du coup
enfin les jets sont devenus comme ça et
c'est ainsi donc en fait je pense que le
niveau de jeu en soit si meilleur parce
que meilleure qualité mais ce père que
les gens jouent fondamentalement mieux
c'est juste ils savent mieux répéter
ouais c'est pas dire que tu es bien
compris mais bien comme il faut
non mais j'arrive là j'aime bien comme
il fait en fait puisqu'il a vraiment
cherché à comprendre le jeu il peut te
citer oui ça me rappelle t-elle partie
machin la caisse n'appartient pas à ça
et c'est pas juste du par coeur et ils
savent pas ce qu'ils savent mais basique
il a cherché à comprendre la mécanique
profonde de trucs pourquoi ça marche
comme ça pourquoi ce cavalier les
pourris là et pourquoi les bien pourquoi
exception ces six s'efforcent et 5 c'est
de la merde enfin il a cherché à
comprendre les finesses et bon
évidemment il est obligé maintenant de
faire de leur dire en tant que seconde
en quoi mais il aura toujours cette
finesse où il aura compris mais ce qu'on
peut pas tous faire enfin il a passé des
heures et des heures et des heures
mais j'aime bien mais c'est pas le même
monde heures tu vois je ne sais plus
utile de travailler pour comprendre que
de travailler pour réciter ses plus
beaux et surtout mais bon c'est pas lui
c'est malheureusement c'était la seule
manière de jouer
mais maintenant maintenant ça me dépasse
et enfin pour le coup tu vois tu peux
être champion d'europe
mais mais mais mais ouais après ça
suffit plus ça suffit plus mais les
dommages en fait avant tu comprenais un
truc et avant que les autres aient
compris il faut gagner plein de parti
comme ça m'a bien fait manta unités les
mecs et ils font tourner leur dit et
c'est fini on fait ça n'existe pas par
moments où tu vas jouer elle est déjà
périmés mais domine alors qu'à l'époque
tu jouais une idée les mecs tu fais pas
la nisa l'ordif et qui comprennent aussi
et ce tout à la main et jusqu'à un
certain niveau les mecs étaient même pas
capable de comprendre ni eu d'un vous ai
connu un peu cette époque vite fait quoi
on va dire la fin des banques
la fin de ce1 si c'est bizarre je pense
je pensais qu'il ya un truc jo lire je
pense ça marche et genre d'échec est
proche de honda match 6-3 et de
tourments voilà marché je pense à
marcher très jolies jambes de maths de
l'escalier la cellule et chars qui
arrive
ouais non c'était les échecs à
l'ancienne oui c'était la fin en fait un
mois quand j'ai arrêté ça c'est en train
de se de mourir livré échec et c'était
2005 balordi a vraiment tout changer
alors certains vont dire oui ça tout cas
c'est donc dire non c'est un progrès
apprendre comment veut parce que c'est
vrai que dans le fond ça joue mieux mais
ouais c'est enlevé dans les quelque
chose et c'est pour ça aussi que moi je
suis j'aime bien le 960 finale et je
peux comprendre que les gens aiment
passer ta pas les mêmes repères et c'est
ça je peux complètement l'entendre mais
des choses ça pourrait aider à raviver
ce truc un peu arrivé la femme
ça pourrait donner l'envié l'envié
d'avoir envie
[Musique]
ces années je pense c'est bientôt la fin
des partis classiques et je sais pas
mais un problème c'est que déjà capable
encore y penser ça il ya longtemps qu un
peu bloqué un siècle avec sa carte
blanche
mais non mais non clairement vous l'a
déjà dit plein de fois me produis
raccourcir les cadences ça serait
vraiment un truc à faire
oui moi aussi je pense que l'évolution
n'est pas dans le neuf cent soixante
années dans les cadences
après la grosse question que je me pose
aussi pour les échecs c'est que là dans
les échecs financièrement on sait que
c'est un jeu qui est pas trop viable et
qui tient surtout surface je parle des
drones hydrospeed jean sename monde sort
françois guy mais est en fait je me dis
que
ça va forcer les organisateurs et les
gens qui cherchent de l'argent à
chercher vraiment des formats qui
intéresse le public parce que il me
semble que ça va devenir de plus en plus
difficile de trouver des mécènes qui
donne de l'argent dans un monde où il va
y avoir une crise due à un prêt je sais
pas je suis pas devin mais je pense que
ça va faire cammas et malo à l'économie
mondiale et du coup j'ai quand même
cette impression se dire je dois me 3 et
au cavalier nicloux dans les deux sens
ouais double lame adro cinq ans je me
suis dit que j'allais la faire bon il ya
bien johnny chan donc ouais bon je t'ai
donné on a ils repèrent le cavalier du
coup les blancs gros passe mieux d'un
coup parce que le renard alors beaucoup
plus faibles les plus fous d'amour qui
attaquent les peut-être fois justice
pour faire une enfilade moi c'est pas
mal il peut faire échec à faire quelques
échecs morgan minutes il devrait prendre
un peu son temps pour réfléchir un
restaurant bon ajout très vite et c'est
pas des mauvais coups mais en fait
compte à une minute tu peux bien prendre
30 secondes pour ce que tu peux pas
mates et surtout 15 à 17 secondes et met
fin à ce genre tu as un truc comme dame
g5 peut parler faire mal tu prends ta
main et trois échecs un moment donné tu
perd cependant le ton non mais là
peut-être des gens puisque on en reçoit
virus john kotter comme un peu ratée
puis à dambach échec qui arrive notre
côté qu' il veut coulisses et des fonds
comme ça se fasse graver un club sain
peut-être tout reprend f4 fait que trois
là malheureusement il a laissé est
remonté mais lui n'a pas de temps mais
c'est chaud ces choix du go tout tout
tout peut se passer dans ce parti et m'a
fait tout reprend et f2
pas peut-être mais je pas les noirs sont
bien mieux mais je pense ça va être nul
le plus objectivement à tord g20 dont le
contour de monampteuil clairement partie
à rebondissements aux femmes total total
est en faite aux gays globalement
lennart meri de la victoire ils ont
dominé tout le monde mais bon nettoyage
5 c'est comme une idée mais je crois en
avoir votre voeu cillit bang pour tous
pour les blancs c'est normal ça je peux
comprendre mais quand les blancs sont
ont pu revenir
il faut prendre dessous faut prendre le
temps de souffler et de se dire ok on me
sens vraiment je suis mieux je peux
gagner et je veux c'est gagner
il est dommage c'est fois faut le
prendre ce temps enfin une minute c'est
beaucoup et c'est rien mais y'a pas de
raison de jouer aussi vite mais non non
mais c'était parfait marrante citron
pour bancaire c'est qu'ils les gaillards
qui joue basse de gens qui jouent dans
le lard et n'a rien à du jour donc je
sais pas qui sait exactement quand je te
dire leur pseudo comme toi tu peux les
voir mais je connais pas je connais pas
c'est un individu seul à l'atonie
l'économie repartira hyper fort vous
inquiétez pas trop mais qd on verra mais
je m'inquiète pas plus que ça mais je me
trompe pas ce que ça retarde forme
non mais c'est possible on l espère en
tout cas mais mais bon je pense a quand
même créé des mutations personnellement
et peut-être que peut-être que du coup
ça va permettre qui est plus rapidement
des parties rapides après je sais pas ce
qu'ils vont prévoir que qui suit avoir
comme trois des chèques là dans l'est
dans les mois à venir
toi tu vois quoi comme jean lasseille
que phil cas pourquoi tu penses que ça
va être maintenue le grande classe tours
paris déjà début juillet tu penses à red
bull
non mais moi je suis sûr c'est un mais
je m'attends à potentiellement ne pas
pouvoir rejouer chaque mois un an et
demi dingue
ok je sais le truc je vois qu'on a le
plus pessimiste fois le plus faim plutôt
pessimiste mais ce que je veux dire par
là un single
tant que le virus road josé chaque je
trouve que c'est dangereux entre
guillemets parce qu'on n'est pas les
conditions de côté pour soigner contre
ce virus
hier qu'on joue dans une salle fermée
mieux confiné avec beaucoup de monde on
est agglutinée les uns sur les autres
rapprochements physiquement des proches
on touche les pièces je touche la pièce
ont atteint l'âge où je joue sa pièce on
touche d'un truc tu as on nous dit les
gestes barrière moment là il ya aucune
barrière ses portes ouvertes est il donc
le tout cumulé j'aime pas ça on peut
être parce je pense que tant qu'il ya un
risque sanitaire c'est dangereux quoi
donc
c'est potentiellement possible deuxième
truc même si ça on trouve quelque chose
qu'on te fait jouer des gants je sais
pas quoi je pense pas que ça va repartir
de gerland demain baguette magique on
reprend tout il y aura des limitations
dans une personne parce que ce sera cinq
mille 5000 sens à 100 je sais pas mais
donc les open d'échecs où tu peux avoir
son personnes 200 personnes nous quoi
peut-être que là ça sera illégale sans
même parler de tout chez pias tu vois
donc en fait qui sait ça peut être dans
très longtemps le prochain tour après
ben non on a la chance de pouvoir jouer
sur internet donc peut-être qu'il faudra
créer des conditions sur internet un peu
plus façon six apart sur internet ça à
partir en cadence rapide c'est sûr non
mais sharks vie et j'espère le plus
dangereux du monde
ben moi je vais pas aller jusque là mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que si le
virus est là il pour l'instant n'a pas
trouvé comment le soigner ni comment on
n'a pas de médecin
donc en fait tant que tu as des cas que
ça doit repartir toi je préfère qu'on me
dise bon ben je vous posais chaque est
monté on ne fait pas de confinement ou
quoi qu'on fasse un nouveau foyer et que
pose la tendance arabe de partout c'est
bizarre non
kate et cinq noms mais juste en p3 et
fit piéger 5 c'est parce que kelly 4 x
100 m dos et 100 kg cinq corps rh un
moule
ah oui mais ok tu dois jouer dix coups
pour abandonner du coup ils pouvaient
pas cliquer il a dû y cohabitent chez
smart sur franzen a repris tous vents
bat ou je sais pas j'ai un moment comme
ça va se finir ce confinement je sais
pas quand mais tôt ou tard quand même
pouvoir prendre des choses offensivement
j'imagine n'est que pour le coup je vois
bien les échecs reprendre après d'autres
activités qui dit je suis en pharmacie
officio nous a dit que le confinement
c'est minimum 31 mais bon sait pas à
quel point c'est peut-être une source
c'est une source cristalline mais c'est
sa mort ça m'étonnerait pas après on
peut avoir de la chance et ça se passe
bien et je le souhaite mais grandir si
une option en fait c'est fin c'est donc
possible que en fait pour un bon puisque
joseph pour revenir ce truc de base fab
du coup est ce que pour toi ça peut
mener vers une vers le fait que voilà il
faut être plus efficient économiquement
et être plus intéressant pour les
sponsors les gens et qu'on a moins de
moyens avec du coup pas sera beaucoup
plus facile d'organiser un gros tournoi
rapide sur trois jours et qui payent
plus regardées qui va être
financièrement moins coûteux puisque les
joueurs tu les fais venir moins
longtemps donc forcément c'est moins
coûteux pas j'avais quand même un truc
qui est plus intéressant en termes de un
nombre de spectateurs
deux coups de couteau moins d'argent
c'est plus loin d'argent et c'est plus
rentable donc elle dit comme ça s'avère
logique je dis enfin en place le truc ça
sert à rien- de chialer parce qu'on va
pas lancer un plan donc il faut chercher
des solutions et trouver des trucs
intéressants et à ça ça peut être une
solution bâton à dos des trucs auxquels
on n'a pas pensé je sais pas vous mais
quand ça a l'air intéressant
non mais est ce que tu penses du coudon
même si c'est pas comme ça du coup moi
je pense que ça a forcé à faire évoluer
le truc est co organisé des tournois qui
coûte 1,5 2 3 millions d'euros pour
avoir dix mille personnes sur twitter ça
ça va peut-être pu être possible ce
serait pas mal en fait très bon coup
mais bon mécanisme armand détroit comme
ça tant que tu a déçu tout ce qui est
aux manettes
il va bien non lui a donné un nom c'est
très bien d'ailleurs du jour n'étaient
pas en danger machin mais c'est pal
c'est pas que la fille de nta c'est
aussi tout les mêmes beaucoup de ton a
privé que ce soit en russie 6 aux états
unis que ce soit à les grandes chaînes
tour les machins et tout est du coup pas
juste moi j'ai cette impression là que
après peut-être y aura pas de crise
économique et que je me trompe
complètement mais s'il ya quand même
beaucoup moins d'argent qu'avant général
dans le sport vraiment les footballeurs
qui demande de beaucoup de clubs qui
demandent à avoir un une baisse des
salaires enfin on a eu peur quand même
beaucoup de conséquences sur le sport en
général et je vois pas pourquoi les
échecs passera à travers parce que c'est
trop long mais moins rentables que
d'autres corps et donc je me dis que
dans ce monde là est ce que finalement
ça n'a pas forcé a plus pensé au public
qu'avant et moins se dire bon on a de
l'argent public qui tombe on a des
mécénats quittons on fait ce qu'on veut
et machins et que ça va forcer à se dire
bah maintenant on va quand même être
obligé de se dire qu'il ya un public et
qu'il faut faire quelque chose qui
plaisent aux gens parce que on peut pas
être fou le casque le dire non monsieur
bah vous tombez 1 ça serait pas mal non
tu vois sur un intérêt plus de monde
vous des meilleurs formats toute façon
serait plutôt bien donc par la force des
choses peut-être qu'on arrivera donc sur
un truc très bien alors faites moi
j'espère toujours dans un truc négatif
en fait trouvé un truc positif et je me
dis est ce que si ça permettait de faire
ça ce serait très bien quoi non mais
bien faire pas de façon on peut se
lamenter on n'avancera pas vous chercher
des solutions et cherchait donc si à
moins de budget et moins de budget mais
hier on ferait un truc adapté est ce que
veut pas dire que ce même dit autant de
budget on va pas calmer c'est de faire
un truc bien malgré tout mais je pense
que parfois avec moins d'argent tu peux
faire mieux
ouais ça peut arriver quand mon
expérience personnelle de vie je pense
qu'il faudrait confirme que c'est
possible peut être malin c'est de bien
faire les choses avec passion
et pas que mon âme il s'en est ce qu'il
ya des choses
aziz et m'a franchement ce que je te
recommande ses 67 c'est juste de prendre
un abonnement de chasse comme tu peux
prendre le or au début qui doit être à 3
euros par mois tu peux même prendre le
diamant si tu veux voir plus de choses
et plus bosser mais c'est à deux mois de
confinement tranquille où tu peux bosser
tu te prends le diamant bouge pas
peut-être même à 9 euros j'en sais rien
mais peu importe ça va te coûter 18 ou
27 euros ce sera l'équivalent de en
termes de travail de 20 à 30 livres ce
que tu auras les exercices tactiques tu
auras les finales tu auras les cours sur
le milieu du jeu donc tu auras tout un
tas de cours et au lieu d'avoir acheté
cette huile yves que tu auras du mal à
lire qui ce qu'on fasse il à se faire
livrer et compliqué voilà pour moins
cher en fait tu vas avoir beaucoup plus
de matériel pour bosser donc je pense
que ça peut être une bonne chose et en
plus tu pour analyse était parti sur une
chaise comme alors dit gratuitement donc
tu as quand même pas mal de choses à mon
avis intéressant donc si je te
recommander quelque chose c'est ça et tu
as les 125 leçon qui sont en français
aussi nos coeurs patate pas bosser
conseils pour progresser
la capote masque est très content
l'abonnement de chasse comme aussi il
est masqué mais mais heureux mais
heureux one on m'écoute on verra bien
s'ils sont là c'est très dur d'arriver
recul très deux soirs dans le monde dans
lequel on va avancer
si ça peut être aussi juste un petit
passage comme ça qu'on revient on
retombe sur nos pattes et tout va bien
ou enfin tout va mal enfin presse chacun
fait comme il veut mais on sait pas et
autant dire pour les échecs bon bah je
pense je m'attends à ce qu'ils aient
beaucoup de tournants du lait qui sera
pas facile alors peut-être qu'une ligne
de films cup avec dix joueurs sera
possible après deuxième truc j'ai pas
encore dit c'est que peut-être on n'est
pas tous sortir de la crise sanitaire au
même rythme et donc certains pays ne
prend pas aux frontières tranché e
d'autrui je sais pas disons l'estonie
soit fermée tu fais quoi d'années comme
caruana un peu plus mûr et je joue pas
ou voilà non c'est à genève que tu vas
voir aussi ce genre truc est donc tout
ça pour dire que finalement détour
nation interne
un jeu plus rapide ou quoi ça a du sens
vu de loin comme ça ex card stud au 2
quai de queyries du rire jaune sur tu as
comme écoute je sais pas on s'est écrit
pendant les candidats n'a de trois
reprises faudrait que juré crimée pour
absolue pour les douze questions bas il
m'a pas proposé de m'interviewer tu as
dû se dire non je n'étais pas faire les
discussions avec ce conte non mais je
sais pas avec absalon se parle aussi de
temps en temps mais juste je pense tu
veux faire les tous question avec des
gens qui sont vraiment à l'union
divulgués mais ce qui est normal tout
pour le 2 wii et qui est in rouge
louis-ii voudront l'antisionisme que
fils bon on verra enfin s'ils peuvent la
faire vivre ne vont pas se gêner
mais après tu par des problèmes
pratiques comme ça de voir de frontières
ouvertes de trucs jamais wimbledon au
tennis aimerait bien organisés ils sont
même pas sûrs pour en faire llodra a
bien voulu voir les faire ben faut
porter bon sens dans un envoi
semblablement donc on verra en fait rien
je vous avais prévenus qu'on peut avoir
conçu moesha qu'ils existent ailleurs
juste nous le bon on a cette chance
d'avoir internet va pas faire un match
de tennis sur twitch peu plus ou moins
détournés sur deux chez ce cas vous quoi
et ça c'est cool
donc ça peut sauver le truc ça peut
paraître d'augmenter les cadences devant
un nouveau public de tout c'est pas bon
parce qu'on veut quoi mais il faut
accepter le changement aussi un
changement c'est maintenant je t'offre
une si si j'avais beaucoup d'obstacles
mais un très bon très bon jeu mais
qu'est ce que je voulais dire c'est pas
le même tennis que comme je peux faire
football manager j'aime bien et je
jouais vraiment [ __ ] de trucs
différents sets 3 6 6 3 mais c'est
dommage qu'il faut c'est un pont l'air
assez longtemps dans la partie ils des
banques payent 6,3 g 6 à 2 pouces et 3
classique 1 le purin qui passe il a
rétabli quoi la fin du live via laquelle
bat maastricht vous accomplissez partie
contre jean founou basoche et c'est quoi
alors ton pseudo sur czech comme la
capote mosquée j'ai déjà oublié il avait
écrit alors qu'ici ça ça calme j'ai
repris la fin à 5 à 2 et poussé trois
petites amies liste bientôt au nom aïe
aïe aïe paris laisse là pour m6
il va défendre un peu de la promotion
sept mois il veut maintenant on sait pas
comment mais ces deux projets c'est
chaud quoi pareil jour avec les blancs
qui jouent très très très vite
j'en reviens je sais bien que ces
décisions si rapidement et jean pourquoi
les cours sont plus chers que les tiens
enfin les gens sont sur quoi je ne sais
pas je croyais que tu étais arrivé
gheskio nas les miens j'ai écrit sur les
sites comme moi j'ai mis 60 euros mais
juste que moi je peux accepter plus
personne n'a du coup je augmenter les
prix pour que les gens n'écrivent plus
ou pas ou qu'ils écrivent quand même
mais si les gens écrivent quand même
mais moi je marche on ne risque rien
pour le coup des gens n'écrivent pas il
te met le bail t'inquiète pas je faisais
plus rien le point faut que les gens
travaillent va perdre
balade et blanc gagne mais comment il a
fait pour perdre ça à la gn je sais pas
il n'a pas voulu faire mal face à
refaire douce il était complètement
gagné un an mais restant chic mais mais
mais mais n'ont jamais atteint
oui je te fais pas pris part au vote 4
parmi on va quand même heureux de
montrer quoi parce que c'était quand
même intéressant juste au lieu de haas
un bref si c'est bien joué et bloque le
fou mais qu'on ne veut plus revenir sur
la diagonale il suffit juste de faire à
deux tu tiens ton qui ont poussé trois
turbos de foot ont bien sûr de mon fils
et 3 c est sûr g4 bas juste on défend le
vous savez de l'autre il va pas revenir
défendre c'est pareil c'est gagner car
l'humain
ouais c'est dommage ouais c'est la
déception nada non mais je revenais je
suis produit en fait face jeudi c'est
dommage dommage bonbons biscuits
glonnières points est ce que c'est une
écossaise non une pompe gianni c'est
bien fonctionné ou pas pas terrible mais
jouable une fois de temps en temps mais
c'est pas c'est dommage c'est moins fort
que ça pourrait être parce que ces trois
sur le papier c'est alléchant très à
l'étroit pour faire des quatre que tu
dis oui mais je prends le centre voilà
ça ce serait mauvais points aux
problèmes de ces trois c'est toujours
pareil quand tu te d'ouverture ces
cavaliers apsys ou des 500 prend qui ont
eu quatre étapes alpines c3 pour gagner
ce qu'un hara latine et du coup l'agencé
3 un peu mal et qu'elle est psy c'est un
peu la même idée ça attaquait de quatre
il ya pas qu ils se racontent défend
alors soit tu fais food et 3 mais bon
c'est trois frères des quatre points
cinq francs soit tu fais des trois mais
bah du coup dû faire des trois des
quatre énormes faire des cinq épreuves
le centre et donc ça marche pas hyper
bien cause de ce qu'est la ligue 6 août
dès 5 ans donc c'est l'enfant de choses
déjà beaucoup bien pour les voir et ces
dommages n'ont donc ni et bebo peau qui
veut d'abord regarder les dvd avant de
prendre des cours ok mais très bien très
bien il y en a plein la retraite il ya
la française d'accélérer sur cette base
l'estonienne sur pied ce band il y aura
la pire qu'un de ces jours là perdre ces
camps et je sais pas c'est pas plus de
moyens s'étaient livrés début janvier
j'aurai tout envoyer ils ont bien tous
mais il faut qu'ils mettent en mettant
pages passe pas loin du coup mais qu'on
dit mettre en page en dvd édité et à
long terme qu'ils aient dit ouais ça
soit du montage soit de l'édition ils
ont ils n'ont pas envie de vite de
larges feuilles galère non un nom mais
surtout qu'en fait ils sont assez actifs
jeu
sauf plein de vidéos en même temps et
donc je sais pas par qui commence maison
plein de dignité en même temps alors le
vidic de larges sa tête quoi les tic de
l'enregistrer à l'appui dvd par jour au
travail quoi à l'effet les vidéos pour
chat ce qu'il entend du monde va plus du
tout quoi on l'a vu tout sur le chat ou
y à fond sur de chasse qui aujourd'hui
va demander oui comment est ce que je
pourrais dire différemment en enfilade
ils étaient très mécontents du moins que
lui tu appeler ça un rayon x était très
heureux oui je fais tout refaire meriem
x c'est d'attaquer la pièce à travers
une autre mais bon tu peux appeler sa
région il j'avais un gars un bouquin
pour les enfants en fait c'est appelle
ça rayons x mais enfilade c'est quoi le
problème
bah ils ont changé le terme parce que
sûrement quand tu as dans les écoles les
gamins en fils alaâ en filature non mais
vraiment du goût pour a pour pallier à
ce problème fait sourire ils appellent
ça un rayon x
ce que très précis en réunion tout de
suite c'est un site pour les enfants s
et ça met du coup c'est mieux du coup
j'étais très heureux nice qui a eu une
enfilade de toute la famille ou un truc
comme ça non mais qu'est ce que je veux
dire si si on commence à arcore d'armes
en fils adrien mot technique aux échecs
et même pour qu'on n'aurait pas peur de
dire si les blancs contre les noirs à
saint-jean racisme à merveille en délire
de flammes et rayons x est pas mal en
fait pas un bon pour les enfants ce pas
mal c'est mieux ça évite quand tu donnes
des cours ça te permet de n'être plus
fixés sur le truc technique plutôt que
d'avoir des gamins qui rigole qu'ils
veulent et ils font des blagues là
dessus tout la journée qui se marre à
face à rennes au bout d'un moment c'est
pas le même concept enfila des rayons x
sont il est vrai qu'en les bouquins jay
pour les gamins ils appellent rayons x 1
bon enfin bref peu importe mais non plus
donc ça sera des rayons x et unix et une
enfilade par derrière et c'est sa
novlangue notre langue ses rayons x
aussi ouais mais en france et à paris
les blés nouveau bouquin sur 20 que
j'avais sur les points les gamins
s'était traduit rayons x est enfin vrai
que le lien du tournoi mais il est finie
la donne
j'ai gagné et 20 kg a gagné à passer
manque la volaille un bon c'était chaud
il a fait découvrir série de launière 72
qui a gagné cette partie avec le dire
quand son amie n'a pas pu le finir en
fait c'est ça ouais ouais ouais c'est
dommage pour lui aussi gagné non je
t'assure que les gagnants il tenait
c'est dommage c'est parce qu surface
c'est la vie enfin les chemins celui
attendu et julien et qui a eu du mal
devant rien il était bien julien est
aujourd'hui 7 sur 9 hilare et
économiques que nous que nous et du coup
est ce qu'on peut voir les parties de
capotes la semence est pas qu'ils
aillent voulait absolument qu'on voit
une ou deux lui on peut regarder une
contrainte genre qu il voulait voir ses
frappes tout plaisir mais on sait pas
son nom m'est arrivé une concurrence ou
alors si on trouvait parti de jean foule
comment allaient les parties comptent
jouer les gens en fait je déchire cette
peur que tu dis est vrai non en fait
c'est bon et il jouait à temps fire iv
très pédagogique
ouais mon coin sans la théologie est
très bonne
de part et d'autre de coeur serré
toujours l'histoire des questions de
pions non mais l'a bien fait tout cas il
faut dans sa carrière très heureux ouais
bon ça développe cette cloud c'est dans
tous les sens
c'est un peu dommage ça on guérit grand
roque et lage voix contre à
contre-courant ya deux menaces matt bat
pas mal qu'est ce qu'on peut dire pour
les noirs faut que tu fais est de fait
un truc quand tu là car open et
conflictuelle blanche est parti et
d'arles et qui ont donc tu pars des
cloches par l'abattre à dégainer à
quatre baies 5 comme les ventes ont fait
et ça se peut être chiant faut vite
troqué en général pour pas avoir plus de
chronique peut pas dire c'est pas mal
tout ça mais là monsieur dans la partie
sait même pas si grave que six bien sûr
cailloux 5 juste sur 120 mais ça ne
t'intéresse pluie à part toi tu es
tranquille avec la cistude est un
adversaire faire ce qu'il a fait il pas
mal tu peux pas reprendre ce que
superbus est ce que tu as et la tête
déjà il faut un projet ça que je sais
pas c'était une option pour comprendre
cet événement à voir avec 6 ou je ne
sais quoi au franchissement première
option
maintenant il a pris le bon et là au
lieu de faire grands axes une qui est
prend bessin gagne action il menace la
fourchette ans et 7 ans tués à éviter de
repartir je sais pas quoi et lui fait
pirogue aussi par exemple il a juste
perdu 20 cents à cette recommandation
du coup bien rockets et voilà après
c'était pas mal du tout ce qu'est des
six échecs paraît fait quoi
la capote masquer d'autres questions
donga
donc donc va me prendre au restaurant 17
mais ce n'est pas bête de faire d'anne
frank si on prend un tour un match parce
que sinon c'est également des tanks et
des 6 c'est à dire oh que oui puis en
plus dense à des rockets et d'un premier
à donner ça me prend v4 aussi puisqu'il
y avait plus de sa défense est une garce
de fuite pour trois des plus de maths en
1/2 bout les blancs sont bien mesdames
feront cavalier même route de bullx est
longue
ouais bon du coup ils rient mais je
pense que dans la partie je l'aurais vu
je suis plus dans le truc ça va pas
aurait du coup merci à tous et on se
retrouvera demain pour 13h15 être alors
qu'avec quand les taux demain après
demain cornetto 20 au lundi à la
prochaine je sais pas quand mon pour un
temps lundi mardi anne on attend on est
dimanche
l'ani monéteau mardi sa mère smartphones
et alors